muy buenas tardes que tal está dicho saluda sergi sánchez en lo que creo que
es la quinceaba clase práctica del curso de trading algo límico
la penúltima de podemos decir las emisión está comenzando todos los
como decirlo porque haremos haremos una más me voy a explicar mejor me voy a
explicar mejor hoy habrá clase el martes que viene habrá clase en principio ambas
clases lógicamente como siempre respondiendo preguntas y de gestión
monetaria y por folio y habrá una clase más que ya está programada ya os lo os
lo digo con tiempo es más o menos un mes después como ya dije de más o menos
con un poco más de margen vale con si no es 11 de junio verdad alberto pilar
se me confirma es lo que es 11 de junio a ver que lo tengo por aquí lo voy a
mirar
11 de junio vale 11 de junio os llegará a los mismos avisos de siempre
perdón pues espera que no he preguntado no he preguntado
me escucha todo el mundo y parece que no de verdad ya con las rutinas finales se
lo he hecho cada vez lo de preguntar y hoy justamente no lo he preguntado a ver a
ver si si veo que sí he vio que sí vale a ver que dice que no que no escucha
bien vale vale era el era el perfecto perfecto justo hoy lo pregunto y mira
bueno decía entonces clase hoy podemos decir normal clase martes que viene
día 7 de mayo vale 7 de mayo principio normal y luego 11 de junio por decir un
mes después un mes después otra vez clase igual de 6 a 9 o hasta que
acabemos si veo que tengo que empezar media hora antes por empezar media hora
antes y hubiera una acumulación de preguntas pero principio no vale porque
un mes bueno porque no todos vais al ritmo del curso y los que vayáis al
ritmo tenéis la ventaja de poder volver a durante este mes repasarlas los que no
tendrán la ocasión de avanzar más y pues básicamente en esa clase se
atenderán preguntas cualquier duda cualquier pregunta que haya y que
idealmente realmente la podéis en el discord pero si no pues ya sabéis que
también podéis enviar e-mails pues en esa clase se repasará también si
hubiera quedado algo pendiente de entregar a nivel de material que sé que
tengo cosas pendientes
a nivel de no sé de veros algo pues se iría poniendo el disco durante este mes
de acuerdo de decir no no también ese mes ahí pues ahí hay margen para o o no
acabará algo o no acabará algo de el porfolio que digo pendiente pues en esa
clase lo haríamos vale lo haríamos 11 de junio si si es 11 de junio ya está
por la mano que es igual es martes es un día de exactamente igual en el sentido
mismo día misma hora martes 6 de la tarde vale que es como digo pues
aproximadamente un mes después de la de la última vale para
ya digo es una clase que acabaremos cuando acabemos esperemos poder acabar en
tres horas pero si hay dudas y tal estaremos ahí respondiendo hasta las
10 hasta las 11 a las 12 hasta la una hasta las 3 de la mañana pedimos un
globo lo que sí pero pero entendemos que no es que no queremos decir que quiero
decir que no vamos a dejar ninguna pregunta que se haya planteado si
responder eso eso será así haremos maratón haremos un extensible si
hace falta de acuerdo se hace vale esto por un lado por otro ya lo pusimos creo
en el disco ahora incluso que te envió un email habéis visto que se envió una
encuesta esto fue un fallo nuestro por qué porque en la plataforma del del go
to meeting si perdón esa mira no sé si estaba grabándose hay que programar las
clases en el inicio programamos un montón en plan no haremos tantas ni de
coña haremos tantas programamos en plan muchas y se acabaron la semana pasada
entonces sin darnos cuenta porque pues eso no lo miras es una configuración
interna que en principio ya la hicimos al principio y no la miramos y resulta
que sí que acabamos esa es esa fecha que pusimos en plan ya que decimos es loca
es seguro que ya hemos acabado fue la pasada la semana pasada entonces de
pronto nos dimos cuenta porque vimos que recibimos también nosotros la encuesta
mensaje se ha enviado la encuesta y digo hostia cómo es que se ha enviado la
encuesta esa encuesta se debe enviar en el en el último mensaje de la clase
automáticamente y por eso se envió los que la habéis respondido perfecto los
que no la habéis respondido pues ya podéis usar ese mensaje o os llegará
otro posterior al día 11 cuando se acabe el día 11 enviaré ese mismo mensaje o
es el que ya habéis recibido ese mismo igual el que el que prefiera esperar a
esa clase va a responder es lógico y coherente diría yo la verdad que
gracias ya los que habéis respondido general todo lo respondió muy
positivamente muchas gracias pero insisto que podéis responderla hasta hasta
el día 11 que se volverá a enviar y eso de hecho era lo lo normal porque solo
debería haberse enviado esa vale lo de la pasada en realidad fue un error pero
pero bien y que la ha respondido pues ya está si alguien la ha respondido y a
que a las tercera clase dice oye que quiero cambiar pues que nos envió el
email y nos diga lo que lo que ha cambiado
vamos al disco vamos al disco vamos al disco esto lo veis luego pero ahora de
momento vamos al disco que mira no lo tenía no lo tenía abierto pero vamos al
disco vale teníamos teníamos cositas teníamos aquí teníamos aquí preguntas
que se habían acumulado bueno ya cuando es una que en el bar porque no era el bar
pues no sólo respondemos pero ya ya contesté por lo tanto la dejo la dejo
por respondida bueno aclaro algo por eso la puse porque porque es verdad que es
interesante ya le reís el preguntaba por este fragmento de código este es un
truco típico de cualquier lenguaje en realidad vale para poner esto en la
vaga de entrada es verdad que en easy language esto no es necesario vale
os explico bien esto porque ahora ya estas alturas y que hablamos un poquito
más que al principio de programación vale pero easy language tiene lo que
llamamos los stops predefinidos vale los stops perdón stops y te pes y varias
cosas pero eso que habéis visto set stop loss por ejemplo set profit target set
trailing hay varios vale la ayuda los podéis ver enseños de estos los esto es
lo que llamamos le llama los built-in stop reserved word vale hay varias
palabras que veis va aquí las veis aquí abajo vale set profit target hay varias
palabras de este de este tipo este tipo de stops automáticamente ya van en la
barra de entrada tenéis todos el curso de easy language inicial o casi todos y
ahí está explicado para repasarlo vale que desventaja tienen que no puede
separar largos y cortos es la única en realidad si tú quieres poner largos y
cortos ya tienes que hacerlo distinto entonces ese código que veis ahí que
pusimos en ese código por cierto ahora os lo voy a enseñar porque porque lo he
evolucionado bastante lo conscientemente conscientemente lo
pusimos siendo un poco absurdo es decir entre ese son hacer esto es absurdo
porque ponerse de estos los set stop loss es absurdo porque el que pongas ya sin
market position o sea lógicamente cuando usas esta sentencia no hay que ponerlo
dentro de un if de market position hay que ponerlo fuera directamente en la
raíz del código porque porque se ejecute siempre si yo le pongo una
restricción le digo y market position entonces sí que se ejecutará en ese
momento porque yo le he implementado una restricción como yo he hecho en esta en
esta imagen pero esto si no hubierais usado set stop loss por ejemplo hubierais
usado by to cover next bar a 5300 esto vale así se haría de acuerdo esa sería
la manera de hacerlo en el primero en el primer bloque el caso del el caso de
que market position distinto de 0 es true vale es decir cuando es market
position distinto de 0 pues cuando está largo cuando está corto pero bueno si
lo separara de largos y cortos podía cuando market position es igual a 1 o
mayor o igual que 0 o distinto de distinto de de menos 1 por ejemplo también
se puede hacer hay distintas maneras pero digamos para si yo me quiero
referir al lado largo de acuerdo pues poner la instrucción del barrio del la
de largo con by to cover bueno pero con sel no para cerrar el largo pongo sel
vale y en el el pondría igual el sel pero con un cálculo que si os fijáis
sólo cambia insisto que eso está hecho expresamente aquí uso enterprise porque
lógicamente he entrado aquí no puedo usar enterprise porque si es si esto no
es true que es falso quiere decir que market position es igual a 0 o sea este
bucle esta estructura se ejecuta sólo cuando market position es igual a 0 vale
por lo tanto yo ahí no tengo entre price por eso uso close vale esto insisto
cuando uso estas estructuras no hace falta pero si tú usas un sel o usas un
by to cover esta es la manera vale pues por eso pusimos esta estructura para que
ya la tuvierais aunque repito otra vez en set usándose de stop loss y set profit
target si no separó largos de cortos si el stop es el mismo en ambos lados es
simplemente con una única línea que ponga set stop loss el stop y se profit
target el target se acabó dos líneas no hay que hacer nada más creo que ya está
claro esto pero era interesante por eso quería aclararlo la clase aunque sea del
bar vale venga vamos preguntas las preguntas aclaro por cierto que la
responde la clase porque creo que es útil para todos vale siempre habrá gente
que no yo lo sé cuando uno hace una clase para tantos alumnos habrá gente
que le parezca bien un estilo el otro yo lo asumo yo entiendo al final hago lo
que creo que es mejor en general y que perjudica menos porque porque perjudica
en que vamos más lentos pero por eso llevo 15 clases inicialmente vamos a
hacer 25 horas me entiendes o sea llevamos 15 con hoy vamos a decir 17 que
son son más de 50 horas más del doble de lo previsto entonces vale voy más
lento pero hago más horas al final el que tenga más o yo por eso adopte este
este modelo de responder en directo porque entiendo ya ha habido a alguien que
me lo ha comentado y lo entiendo insisto pero por eso hago más horas para si
tratar de contentar a todo el mundo el que realmente las preguntas dice vaya
tiempo perdido porque esto ya lo sé y el que no hoy lo valoran entonces creo que
así tratamos de contentar a todo el mundo que insisto que siempre es
difícil pero yo lo intento entonces vamos con más con más preguntas
decía la de alejandro no más arriba porque está alejandro está alejandro si
está ya lo había leído si finalmente lo hicimos intradía que ha estado haciendo
pruebas con el adx como sabes pero tirando de código esto creo que se
refería a ver a lo miré lo miré el otro día al boling era o al revés a mi
reversión creo que la mi reversión no esperate que vuelvo a dar si al mil
reversión sí que sí que hemos hecho algo más de esto eso alberto sobre todo
ha estado trabajando más está centrado más en el money management y el
portfolio
hoy vamos a hacer más veréis también por folio pero más centrado en el money
management vale y el siguiente día veremos también por folio pero más
centrado por folio entonces seguramente el próximo día veremos todos los
sistemas que hemos visto que ya los tengo a no lo abierto porque lo hizo el
ordenador los tengo por aquí ya en una plantilla casi todos montados pero
prefiero empezar primero por el mone maras entonces pero sí sí que sí que
hay el adx en principio son filtros pero hay hay muchos no no ya es ahora ahora
os enseñaré cuando acabe esto el código que lo evolucionado más para
ayudaros de filtros también tenemos algo por ahí a ver si antes del último
clase podemos también añadir algo de eso pero ahí hay un tema también de
búsqueda hay un tema de búsqueda ahora ahora os voy a conocer el código
hablamos de ello pero hay un tema de búsqueda yo he dado dos genéricos de
volatilidad y de de tendencia muy genéricos incluso de tendencia se
puede componer en sus componentes el de volatilidad es un ejemplo y puedes usar
desviación típica
puedes usar otros cuales al final no dejan de ser ejemplos puedes buscar
figuras de velas eso y lo hemos comentado los rbs por ejemplo los narrow
range los white outside bars inside bars gaps es decir cualquier cualquier
estructura de precio la puedes implementar a nivel de filtros como ahora
veremos en las entradas y salidas después que ya os lo he dejado listo
este código vale claro que puedes ver más y al final es ese es un poco la
búsqueda pero en un intradirario al final sí que es más bien esa la pauta
lo comentamos se tan básicos se tan sencillo análisis horario vale filtro
que puede ir o no ir de acuerdo no es obligatorio y salidas es un poco el
mecadismo alejandro y en un no es en un min reversión
a ver comentabas que funciona el short que se supone que siempre debería
funcionar sí pero te está siendo imposible bueno ya comenté comenté que
en los últimos años sigue siendo mi reversión o sea sigue yendo bien y
sigue siendo un activo que no es malo pero es verdad que en los últimos años
se han han revertido un poco a la media vale los índices americanos en el
sentido que han ido un poco más hacia la tendencia y los potenciales han ido
bien y el oro por ejemplo al revés de acuerdo también era tendencial y le ha
ido mejor en mi reverso de tal forma que ahora casi podemos decir que tanto oro
como como bolsa pueden ser de ambos lados vale puede ser un poco de ambos lados
aunque tienen más sesgo tendencial en caso del oro commodities y
antitenencial en el caso de índices se pueden trabajar en ambos en ambos
estilos vale y quizás está pasando eso que en los últimos años cuesta más la
revelación en los índices que hace 10 años por entendernos vale cuesta más
ahora que antes antes era más fácil antes era más fácil vale pero el
próximo día lo veremos y si por lo que sea no entramos en detalle me lo pones y
tranquilo que la de último lo veremos y no se queda nada seguro entonces venga
qué más decía también aquí comentaba luego rubén interesante como casi todas
las preguntas que hace rubén por todas son interesantes pero es una persona que
lleva muchos años en el mercado y se nota a lo que iba hablaba de lado
corto decía que en el largo había muchos trades y que en el corto había menos y
que no le generaba le generaba dudas bueno no recuerdo este este que sistema
era te acuerdas tu alberto
el de la última sesión tendencial oro vale bueno es evidentemente que no es
que no es una bueno no es una buena señal es decir que evidentemente es menos
significativo si no no no hay no hay mucho mucho que decir ahora es suficiente
para descartarlo no necesariamente vale no necesariamente es verdad que si tú lo
trabajas de manera conjunta el análisis es conjunto pero no me parece mal que
hagas esa distinción no me parecen no me parece mal no te digo uno rotundo pero
sí que te digo que el análisis es conjunto para eso lo hace ese espejo vale
para eso lo des despejo para eso tienes reglas en ambos en ambos lados de todas
maneras cien trades no son pocos o sea no son pocos son pocos pero que pueden
ser pueden ser suficientes sobre todo si vienen apoyados del largo y luego hay
que ver también por qué no va de acuerdo es decir al final si tú usas un
activo que no hecho más que subir hombre que haga pocos cortos es deseable de
acuerdo decir al final al final es ese es el sentido común del motivo pero que
no no veo mal que tú ante esa inquietud al final cuando tiene que tener que
resolver que antes en que tú plantes un análisis separado
no haría un análisis totalmente individual en un activo que se puede
hacer nosotros ahora mismo estamos operando loro así estamos operando
loro así separado pero pero pero ya te digo que la siguiente revisión lo
volveremos a juntar es decir al final como te hemos hablado tú y yo muchas
veces a veces en en otras conversaciones que nos hemos encontrado no existe una
una respuesta única es que es verdad no es que quiera esquivarles que es la
realidad de acuerdo es decir nosotros mismos nos equivocamos fíjate el mes de
abril que llevamos nos han dado hasta en el carne identidad y por supuesto el
vector principal es el mercado pero también pues seguramente hemos
cometido errores en los últimos años y vamos a seguir cometiendo decir no no
ser profesional no te exime de cometer errores y al final hay un aprendizaje
continuo y un prueba error de ciertas cosas porque el mercado es un ente vivo
como te decía ahora cambia ciertas cosas cambia comportamientos y tú tienes que
moverte con él entiendes entonces al final es así y vas a seguir probando
entonces yo el oro aunque aún lo estamos operando separado casi con
otra seguridad que lo volveré a operar espejo
ya digo vale porque no me parece suficiente motivo por la experiencia que
hemos visto para separarlo aunque sí que es una de las commodities que tienen más
sesgo distinto de largo de corto pero el hecho de que de que sea sólo por
tendencia no lo que marcan para mí eso el separarlos es la pauta de volatilidad
de acuerdo y sí que en el oro tiene un poquito más de sesgo abajo que arriba es
decir cuesta más normalmente hay que filtrar más el corto es más más sucio
sabes pareció a la bolsa un poco en eso vale pero no tanto en la bolsa es muy
heavy la bolsa es muy claro cambio en en la en oro no lo es no lo es tanto
aunque un poco también se da vale un poco también se da pero pero ahora por
ejemplo aunque lo hemos operado así pues nos quedamos más por tratar de juntar
otra vez pero bueno veremos veremos vale veremos veremos cómo nos como nos
sale pero porque ha valado 300 trades no no pondría un filtro tan rotundo tan
rotundo como ese porque es es depende es depende también habrá que ver pues
cuánto cuantos grados de libertad tenemos si le hemos optimizado poco ese
sistema se tenía pocas optimizaciones al final era una media sólo si no
recuerdo mal bueno hay que ver hay que ver qué grados y qué depende depende
de los grados de libertad como siempre y de lo que lo hayas optimizado vale si al
final la optimización es leve y demás pues seguramente necesitas menos desde
el final y es un poco es un poco eso no
vale decía alejandro además que tenía casi listas para validar y que tuvo bueno
hay una diferencia por el tema del swap a lo de multichars mira no te lo voy a
enseñar ahora porque si la abro puedo ligar la hora y el último día fue un
desastre pero no tenía preparado perdóname porque te he dicho que sí para
el próximo día apúntate lo abierto por favor que ya lo traeré montado vale para
para porque porque el último día vale sí sí pero pero es que es que es que
abrir ahora multichars sabes que teniendo telestation el último día me
provocó un desastre bastante jevito es prefiero porque tengo tres he preparado
con una cosa y no tenía previsto abrir multichars entonces prefiero no abrirlo
ahora pero pero bueno sí que se puede si al final multichars te lo explico todo
caso tiene es muy flexible en eso vale tiene muchas configuraciones de cómo
configurar el slip page y el comisión puede ser el porcentaje entonces al
final a lo mejor no lo vas a penalizar exacto pero lo vas a poder penalizar con
una comisión fija más uno variable entonces puedes jugar con eso y al
final un swap no deja de ser una comisión de acuerdo un porcentaje de
acuerdo no deja de ser un porcentaje que lo tienes que ir estimando y
aproximado de acuerdo que no será exacto pero no te va no te va a hacer que
vaya o no vaya eso o no debería si lo digo si lo estimas si lo estimas entonces
al final también te digo que si te está pasando esto es porque te gustan mucho
los sistemas de tradía de con muchas operaciones que está bien tienen cosas
buenas pero tienen esta mala vale son muy sensibles a las desviaciones también
al ruido se acoplan más es decir necesitan revisiones más frecuentes y
todo tiene su parte buena su parte mala pero pero bueno si no aunque es verdad lo
dices el swing el swing por ejemplo en apolo que es un sistema swing que
afecta le afecta y claro que le afecta y claro que es la pregunta si la
pregunta es operar futuros o cfds sobre esto no hay debate en el curso he
hablado de eso es mejor futuros eso está claro pero hay veces que por distintos
motivos yo no voy a poder hacerlo en nuestro caso es porque hasta ahora por
ejemplo donde tenemos los dos árboles no nos ha permitido y sabéis aquellos que
nos seguís que es algo que ha provocado hasta tensiones importantes por nuestro
lado porque porque es algo que estaba pedido y hasta acordado hace muchos
años y no se ha dado pero bueno eso es otro tema y es algo que nos sigue
provocando problemas y que sabemos con ningún ningún tipo de duda que
seremos mejores en futuros no hay ningún debate posible antes es decir si tú
puedes es mejor operar futuros pero puede ser que no puedas porque la cuenta
tiene que ser un poco mayor cada vez menos que ya lo comenté porque tenemos
micros tenemos ya buenos micros en tenemos micros en dax operables bien en
cp en nasdaq en oro todo eso es operable en euro dólar también por ejemplo es
bueno tenemos ya bastantes micros y como vais a ver más el próximo clase que
hoy con tres sistemas en tres activos se puede hacer un portfolio muy bueno muy
bueno eso es posible que es mejor con diez sistemas sin claro pero con tres si
nosotros trabajamos tres sistemas con poca correlación entre sí en tres
activos con poca correlación entre sí probablemente diversificaremos de una
manera más que aceptable no aceptable no buena muy buena vale muy buena eso es
posible y lo veremos vale y lo veremos entonces por lo tanto para operar tres
sistemas en cuanto hace falta bueno trataremos de hacer simulaciones sobre
esto cuando trabajaremos lo haremos en porfolio trader o lo haremos en
multichart hay en el maestro vale hoy vamos a ver más msa vale para el
pero veremos para trabajar más esto que os digo ahora tamaños de cuenta mix de
sistemas uno u otro vale usaremos más por folio trader y multichart más sobre
todo el próximo día entonces a partir de ahí si tú puedes si dices he entendido
comentas que en algún en serio también funciona con cpd es pero ahora ya en
algún esero ya se puede hacer futuros yo creo que yo ya también puedo hacer
futuros en cero pero claro a mí me interesaría poder pasar lo que tengo
tienes empezar de cero en futuros bueno me puede interesar para hacer pruebas y
de hecho lo tenemos planeado cuando acabamos el curso de muchas más cosas
pero pero bueno me interesa insisto poder poder poder adaptar o sea lo que
tengo ya que siga ahí con inversores y demás
sería que todos los inversores que tengo pueden operar en futuros no no no yo
tienes eso es lo que a mí me interesa porque porque nosotros ganamos lo que
ganan los inversores vale que más
mantener un sp en el algo es carísimo así para los suaves era una vez es
verdad que son caros eso es así son caros es un tema que tienes que
considerar y ya está pero en cero en cero yo casi casi te aseguraría que ya
puedes hacer futuros en cero el problema es hacerlo en la en la en la
normal donde operas con tu dinero de acuerdo entonces en cero y yo estoy
prácticamente seguro que ya puedes hacer
vale que más que más que más que más esto ya estaba si añadía
vale sí bueno comentamos el futuro en tu siguiente mensaje que será mejor si
si es mejor es mejor lo que lo que explicaba y que eso es así es decir
pensar que el tipo de interés está implícito en el futuro no quiere decir
que los sé y por eso cuando cuando los tipos son altos se separa mucho más el
índice bueno porque porque el tipo de interés lo separa pero pero bueno que
sí que es mejor futuro simplemente lo explicaba como como conocimientos al
final depende si vas largo corto te puede beneficiar o perjudicar el tipo de
interés como poco con opciones no al final el tipo de interés y el tiempo va
sabéis un poco aquellos que sepáis opciones pero sigue siendo mejor el
futuro pero pero daros cuenta que el cfd ahora por ejemplo su justo sobre todo
cuando empieza el vencimiento está un precio x y el futuro está muy pues por
encima bastante por encima porque el tipo de interés lo lleva implícito y en
cambio el cfd lo tiene mediante swap lo tiene fuera pero siento que aún así es
mejor en el futuro vale aquí amarrugada estas que vienen
después no las he leído es decir que las voy a ver ahora las voy a ver ahora
así que confío poderlas responder porque porque bueno de amarrugar las ha
puesto la post hoy y ya no la he leído vale últimas inquietudes en un
escenario de operación en futuros acercarse conviene definir la estrategia
de rolling si no recuerdo mal comentaba con el volumen descendía sé vale voy
leyendo luego luego cuento vale no lo leo todo porque luego lo podéis ver
vosotros en el disco de pregunta aquí
abierto de acuerdo con la estrategia anterior de la miración del día y reabra lo que
tenía abierto en el vencimiento se tiene que hacer a mano
vale se puede automatizar si vale la pena normalmente no normalmente no vale
la pena pero si se puede se puede automatizar lo que se puede
pero normalmente no vale la pena normalmente nosotros cuando hemos operado
siempre lo hemos hecho a mano lo hemos hecho a mano el rolo ahí pues sentido
común amigo al final por ejemplo nosotros cuando operábamos arte misa en
operamos por razones que ya conocéis muchos pues es un sistema tipo apolo
swing pero qué pasa a ver esto mira esto esto es a esto por ejemplo es es
apolo vale que buen largo vamos esto es apolo entonces claro si imagínate que
que yo tengo vencimiento es el viernes vale y se
rola imagínate que el vencimiento es este día y nosotros tenemos el rolo
seis días antes vamos a suponer que es aquí el rolo previsto pero yo veo yo
estoy ahí largo vale y bueno sé que el sistema puede cerrar porque ya lo sé
que puede cerrar entonces pues a lo mejor me espero que cierre y ya si no
cierra pues rolo me entiendes es decir lo que os quiero decir que en los
futuros índices americanos como tienen una ventana muy grande porque porque
ellos vencen el tercer viernes de mes pero por uso y costumbre se suele
rolar entre 5 6 7 días antes es decir desde la semana anterior pero los días
siguientes del rolo óptimo del rolo del gráfico para entendernos
sigue habiendo un volumen más que aceptable donde ya no hay aceptables el
día antes donde empieza ya a ser preocupante es el día antes por ejemplo
entonces tú ahí tienes margen de rolo el cambio de contrato si tú estás en tu
posición tú puedes tener tu día óptimo y puedes hacerlo ahí si quieres
siempre sería pues si tú aquí estabas largo vale imagínate que tienes que
rolar aquí vale pues oye cuando el futuro abre vendes este y compras el
siguiente y está es que no hay más de acuerdo es vendes este y compras el
siguiente y hasta ahí ha rolado pero tú también puedes esperar a ver si
cierra y entonces ya una vez ha cerrado y ha rolado solo explico en el sentido
que te ha cerrado la posición y tú ya la nueva la abres en el nuevo al final el
que a ti te manda vale porque una cosa es la operativa real decir de abrir y
cerrar y la otra el que manda en el mercado vale el que te manda es el
continuo que tú tienes ya rolado por ejemplo en los índices americanos ahora
es 105 xr mediante ratio y cinco días antes porque porque ese es el que tiene
el volumen óptimo eso que decías no yo sé que es ese yo ese lo puedo hacer
operable aquellos que seáis de tres sessions sino el que no pues en otro
sitio mediante aquí este es de tic data pero es igual para que me entendáis vale
aquí en el en el perdón en el custom features vale yo le pongo en eq vale y
aquí ya me sale yo aquí le pongo que rolo cinco días antes vale y le digo
que use este para trading automáticamente me lo hace operable vale
pues ratio perdón como lo hace operable si os fijáis le añade el contrato
veces este es arroba nqm 24 igual 105 xr esto sería operable es decir yo esto le
puedo tirar órdenes a este si le quito esto no le puedo tirar órdenes pero a
este sí le puedo tirar órdenes pero este cuando acabe el vencimiento se
acaba hay que cambiarlo de letra vale pero entendéis ya día entonces yo ya
puedo jugar con ello porque puedo incluso si quiero pues ponerlo en el
vencimiento directo si es intradía yo puedo operar en el nqm 24 o en el
arroba nqm 24 al final al final en esos días pues normalmente tenemos como ya
viste en la teoría tenemos ahí un gráfico que vemos cuando es el momento
óptimo y pues tienes que tener el sistema puesto a lo mejor en el nqm 24 y
también puedes jugar con este día pues le pones 6 le pones 5 le pones 7
dependiendo de que si te interesa o no que refleje el precio del antiguo el
precio del nuevo vale esto es un tema de práctica que no es más que cuando lo
tengáis que hacer en simulado probar el simulado y se ve muy fácil de verdad ya
lo enseñe la teoría pero lo podéis ver poner poner un vencimiento poner el otro
hice una práctica os acordáis que tenía con el sp creo distintos días tenía 105
106 107 108 vale pues tú con eso vas cambiando el día en que se hace el rolo
en ese continuo y con eso pues tú es una manera de jugar el día del vencimiento
si haces esto que te he dicho aquí es decir si haces esto de que te esperas
si no tú quieres ir al 105 pues 105 miras que día es y ese día vendes
compras compras y vendes y está te olvidas cambia se cambia ese contrato de
la m a la n pero que es lo que te digo al final es normalmente lo lo hacemos a
mano se puede hacer por código si se puede hacer por código puede tener un
código muy complejo que tenga todas las letras de los vencimientos y que se
encargue de eso y hasta pero vale la pena pues no no sé si va la pena si no
tienes una cartera muy muy grande seguramente no seguramente no vale la
pena por pragmatismo por el tiempo por recursos por siempre vale los bt que se
usa los bactés no tiene que ser que se usa money management con compounding
como que la mone más me refiero ahora de todo el capital de la posición pero lo
del money management lo de mones management en las bases de bactés es
importante aclarar porque si que he visto que en ciertos momentos de hecho en la
práctica os he fijado o le he usado en algunos y en otros no es decir no
tomarlo como una ley divina de acuerdo es en el caso en que se use recordaros
que os dije que hay que usar humor y management poco agresivo vale
simplemente es para para que la cuent para usar para simular también el
efecto del uso de la cuenta y donde se nota mucho es en bolsa recuerdo en
nasdaq se ve de acuerdo y se nota mucho a lo mejor en otros activos no es
necesario puedes hacerlo con un contrato de acuerdo y no y no pasa nada pero si
lo haces con money management tiene que ser poco agresivo y recuerda que
entonces sobre todo tienes que mirar porcentajes al igual que si no usas
money management tienes que mirar retornos brutos decir el dinero si usas
money management tienes que mirar porcentaje en porcentaje verás que no
es tan abrupto es tan abrupto en no min en valor en valor absoluto porque
además como tenés eso no te pone el gráfico de la equity en logarítmico te
lo pone en lineal pues se te vuelve una curva muy exponencial porque es lo que
dices tú el dinero es mucho más pero el porcentaje debe ser proporcional esa es
la clave rebaja un poco el money management no lo hagas tan agresivo y te
compondrán te compondrá menos o próbalos en componer recuerdos al final
próbalo al final como todo es es es prueba error y tienes que ir viendo un
poco que es lo que encaja más con lo que tú buscas y quieres yo os explico
las maneras de hacerla las que usamos nosotros ventajas desventajas y además
que hay cosas como he dicho antes y que hemos cambiado de opinión y que a
mejor en el futuro cambiamos otra vez es decir esto es así si esto es así al
final hay que ir siempre con la mente abierta y valorando valorándolo todo
cuestionándotelo todo se ve con rigor y con criterio pero hay que cuestionárselo
todo eso es lo que hacen cuando esto ya estaría espera que le pongo el clip
lo de a pome clip a lo de arriba alberto plis para que sí para el raúl
también me lo ha puesto hace un ratito ahí apurando y apurando a lo que es clip
pues no sé por qué no tienes que bueno debe ser de tu y yo no sé qué privilegio
clips locura vale raúl dudas que le han surgido estas son algunas estrategias del
concept y se tenía una conda todos usan un símbolo de tiempo real por ejemplo
net así esto te leí por ahí en algún bar o algo si no permite mezclar
distintos de leyes es es gracioso alguna manera superar ese problema sí claro
que hay pagar el tiempo real de eso o bien usar o bien usar de otro otro data
en caso que se pueda si quieres ver ese específicamente solo tienes que ir a tu
cuenta en el client center es casi fuera del curso de preguntas apilar en el
whatsapp y a nosotros ya te lo explicaremos pero no vale la pena ahora
porque vamos a estar un rato ahí y en el client center la web puede después
pagar ese tipo ahora mismo no recuerdo cuál es hay que mirarlo cuál es supongo
que es el del del del del new york sense pero no se parece que es raro que no
venga es bueno hay que mirarlo hay que mirarlo en que viene que viene también
hay algunos cuidado por ejemplo el tic el tic no deja de ser un indicador que se
atrevería muchos datos que los da como fuente pero algunos a lo mejor los puedes
calcular tú entonces cuidado el tic puede ser que sea uno de ellos el tic
puede ser que sea uno de ellos vale habría que mirarlo habría que mirarlo
vale también dice que probó una autotrend line y le damos resultado se
queda lateral incluso pierde poco la pregunta es a pasar ideas pasar a la
captura aquí a ver es buena curva en comisiones es muy buena curva pero esto
14 24 24 24 14 24 14 hombre tan extremo tiene pinta de sobreutilización pero es
verdad que lo que es posible esto esto pasa sobre todo en los sistemas
tendenciales es algo normal es algo normal todo al final depende un poco y
lo que tiene es un sistema ideal hombre pues puede ser que no lo sea pero si en
una cartera puede puede ser que aporte valor pero sí que es verdad que ahí
sobre todo teniendo tantos trades quizá la solución sería filtrar de acuerdo en
ese caso parece el típico caso de filtrar de buscar algún filtro que
evite que opere ahí no que evite que opere ahí porque es muy excesivo la
diferencia cuidado porque puedes sobre el problema de los filtros problema de
los filtros porque no soy especialmente amigo lo he dicho muchas veces no digo
que no tengan utilidad en entraría nosotros no operamos mucho en entraría
vale pero
entraría tienen su utilidad sin duda alguna y hay que usarlos casi siempre en
entraría o sea que estamos de acuerdo pero mucha prudencia porque es muy fácil
ajustar filtrando de acuerdo es muy muy fácil y a veces yo creo que se abusa de
los filtros para hacer pasar una idea que es justita por buena hay veces si
tiene suficiente estrés como aquí parece pues puede que tenga sentido puede que
tenga sentido que trabajarlo hay que trabajarlo pero al final lo que
comentas y te cuestionas es inteligente y es el camino es decir oye hay un
motivo para este cambio hay que ser muy objetivo muy estéril con los análisis
y cuidado con engañarse que no es fácil pero es verdad estoy de acuerdo en que
el nasdaq este no comentado antes los índices se han tendencializado más por
lo tanto eso es correcto ese análisis desde mi punto de vista y además no
puedes analizar con datos objetivamente por lo tanto es verdad hay una razón que
puede justificar eso hay una razón ahora bien a lo mejor podemos ahí por
lo tanto filtrar con algo razonable que tenga sentido que tenga sentido y que lo
lo mejor es con prudencia y demás o sea que yo miraría de explorar el camino de
los filtros me gusta que trabajes en estar ese concept ya os lo recomendé
ahora tendréis un mes hasta la siguiente clase porque hay material muy
muy útil para hacerlo crecer es decir como os pasé ese excel que también os
trabajé que también creo que puede resultar útil de cómo habían ido las
ideas haber algunas de bien otras mal y algunas poco mal pero no muy mal esas
esas entradas con muchas operaciones pueden pueden tener camino de mejora con
salidas entradas y pueden trabajarse y y pueden dar camino a buenos sistemas de
acuerdo y por eso os he dado todo ese material los del estat para que por
favor huyais de las chubedías de sistemas no son necesarias para encontrar ideas como
veis ideas en esto como hoy te suscribes al año es mucho más barato que que
comprar el strategy cuando el builder que nosotros tenemos por ejemplo es decir
no hace falta de verdad no hace falta y además os podéis hacer pues otros
constructores vale los doctores como el que no lo tengo hecho en el pdf porque
estaba más preparando la clase os lo pasaremos en
os lo pasaré también en paper escrito vale para que lo podáis lo podáis usar
pero aquí lo tengo es lo presento brevemente para que de grabado en el en el vídeo a ver si lo
encuentro a ver si lo encuentro buscador aquí vale aquel aquel código que teníamos de salidas y
demás bueno le he cambiado el nombre le he llamado buscador vale y ahora tiene 23 entradas y 35
salidas acuerdo puede tener más algunas de hecho las he puesto un poco para ayudar para haceros
pensar es decir como un camino de para una entrada por ejemplo clásico clásico de de velas vale os
he puesto una de velas imaginaos las figuras de velas que hay podéis sacar podéis hacer uno de
30 solo de velas solo de velas a por cierto tema de velas para filtros también vienen bien
vale todas las estructuras de velas que lo peor que tienen son el nombre porque viene un nombre de
esos nombres así raros pero al final son cosas muy lógicas son cosas en la mayoría escasos muy
lógicas que reflejan el comportamiento de la oferta a la demanda pueden venir bien para muchos
tipos de sistemas vale la tanto como señal primario como como filtros vale más filtros
qué tipo de vela hay antes o después el hecho de de operar solo cuando hay una o no
operar cuando hay una determinada vela ya lo hablamos el clásico de los breakouts y
los sentenciales normalmente ahí vienen bien los filtros de cuando ya ha habido expansión no
operar tienes normalmente ese tipo de filtros vale ya os lo comenté y los mil reversiones al contrario
al contrario porque porque cuando ya ha habido ya habido expansión normalmente entrar en breakout ya
nuevamente una expansión anticipa contracción pues ahí a lo mejor es mejor operar un mil reversión
entidades en ese momento cuando y cuando el mercado ya está contraído a lo mejor ya es mejor ya no
entrar en un mil reversión porque ya ya está cerca de que acabe ese periodo hay que hay que
jugar un poco con esto y que figuras de velas pueden indicar eso entonces aquí por repasar
brevemente vale ya sabéis va a un input hay un periodo de entrada porque como muchos tienen
pues ya está puesto ahí para directamente ponerlo tanto de entrada como de salida per
per ese vale y luego algunos más tienen algunos inputs más añadido porque lo exige vale pero
veréis que hay entradas pues yo que sé un momento un simple breakout cruce de medias simples hay un
bollinger van en mil reversión hay una expansión de volatilidad de cierre más volatilidad más atr
hay un bollinger va en tendencia lo vimos hay un don chan clásico que es parecido a un breakout
pero es otra manera de ver el breakout hay un que y reverso al que os hable de ellos también puede
venir bien para filtrar y como salida a veces más que como entrada aquí hay uno entrada con pull
back es cierre que no deja de ser un cierre mayor que un cierre anterior y otro de un periodo más
largo es decir en el largo plazo cierres crecientes pero en el corto cierres de crecientes una
corrección vale este sería la 9 vale aquí tiene otro input porque tiene el primario pero luego
tiene un multiplicador para relacionar la tendencia corta con la larga eso es también un truco que
lo uséis así voy a usar una media corta de una media rápida usar un multiplicador multiplicador
porque así las relacionas una con la otra y también un truco como os hablé en los stops y
te pesa bien hacerlo así relacionar uno con otro por un multiplicadores más que con valores
absolutos aquí al revés entramos en el pulva contra la tendencia primaria en este caso el cierre
el cierre de largo plazo bajista pero a corto alcista un poco lo contrario al otro habrá activos que
de una manera de otro aquí un breakout junto a un momento un rsi y aquí tengo tres rsis distintos
residencia sobreventa rsi de expansión bueno podéis usar el rsi podéis usar el estocástico
repito son plantillas con modelos para usarlo vale para usarlo y que podéis vosotros adaptarlo vale
aquí otra manera de mirar un pulva con un percentil de corrección esto creo que se lo vi
no sé quién se lo vio se lo vi a alguien
entre entrada en velas muy expansivas aquí jugando con la desviación estándar en vez de
con la tr para que veáis también otra manera además de añadir la terrestre es como una banda
de bollinger pero en una vela expansiva cuando una vela se expande mucho pues y además el cierre
es alcista vamos a entrar en expansiones mira está por ejemplo para noticias entrando poniendo
tops de largo y corto a una hora concreta esto para noticias hay que explorarlo pues mira yo
voy a operar a las 2 30 el jueves del viernes tal puedes añadir el día pues un sistema especialista
para meter eso a ver qué tal va eso qué tal va el día de paro el primer viernes de mes pues venga
ese día cuando es primero viernes de mes se puede detectar que son fácilmente con código y además
es la minuto antes de un gráfico de minuto yo pongo una orden de esto por arriba de un orden esto
por abajo entro y ahí luego le probo una salida que va aparte eso es entrada salida ya tenemos 30
más por entonces todo esto lo podéis ir combinando combinando de manera realmente
porque aquí por ejemplo con volumen entrando cuando hay volumen bajo puedes hacerlo con alto
también una otra variación de que es reversal aquí viene más el candlestick con martillo vale
martillo candlestick con martillo entrada con un martillo bastante interesante estaba bastante
bien pero además he posado como filtro y os he puesto para que veáis que esto de c hammer
de todas las que empiezan por c aquellos que tengan este distrito es que hay muchas son
funciones candlestick que casi todas creo que están hechas show me's para pintarla vale esto
recomiendo hacer los show me's para ver las reglas en la pantalla y mirar el gráfico de entrada y de
salida vale ver entender las cosas a pintar esto que he dicho qué significa esto de pulva contra
la tendencia primaria vale pues que lo pinte un show me's y así lo veo en qué velas eso se da y
lo veo y lo intento entender y a lo mejor porque a raíz de ahí a lo mejor lo puedo modificar y
puedo modificar la idea y cambiar cosas pero aquí hay un martillo vale de entrada que no sé si os
hice dos si os hice dos la misma al revés y otro breakout con un momento un momento más corto y
momento largo es decir cuando una media de un cierre un cierre sea superior a un cierre de muy
largo plazo y el de corto también entonces cuando se dan esas dos momentos entra entra en el largo
y al revés en el corto y aquí ya repito está el candlestick pero igual que tenéis el hammer pues
podéis probar cualquier tipo de velas están todas y buscáis aquí en el diccionario mismo vale que
están las funciones vale a ver si pongo c a ver si me salen así de manera fácil para que igual
hay mucho no ves con c guión me salen todas ahí están todas las funciones el 23 soldados el bebé
abandonado bueno el nombre es lo peor pero es igual entrar recordaros que está la ayuda y ahí os la
explica vale si no buscáis el internet que es un abandonado baby que encontraréis 74 páginas
que hablan de ello vale entonces lo bueno es que están ya programadas podéis abrir el código para
entenderlas y cambiarlas si queréis vale pero hay un montón las típicas más conocidas hará mi doji
bueno todas gabs alguno talas triple estará de amanecer de anochecer envolventes vale que todo
este tipo de figuras que hay bastante conocidas y bastante usadas por la literatura técnica aquí
las podéis evaluar vale las podéis evaluar porque podéis programarlas y montar una estrategia de
entrada con ellas aquí os he puesto el martillo podemos usar otras con la función que ya está
incorporada y programar en un montón de entradas vale y también también podéis hacer como salida
como entrada entonces ahí están las 23 entradas podríamos haber hecho 74 es decir se ve claro no
pues un ejemplo hecho de resee y varios para que picadores medias pautas de momento de precio
poco de todo no un poco de todo pero solo lo podéis evolucionar lo que quieras esto es al final un
código que permite rápidamente probar ahora por el 23 22 21 y voy probando con un mismo código
buscador de buscador de qué tipo de señales le gusta un activo por ejemplo que tipo de señales
le gusta un activo vale y para salida pues había muchos más el he puesto el cero como no éxito no
entries pero realmente no haría falta sería igual pero lo he puesto para que os quede claro y aquí
ya lo vimos vale esto porcentuales solos aterre un montón vale aquí ven lo empezamos a mezclar
bollinger salidas y he añadido alguno más no recuerdo mal final cierre por don chian cierre
por un momento vale en algunos indicadores típicos de entrada que ir reversal vale aquí os he puesto
si veis que funciona lo podéis meter con algo más pues un don que es reversal más esto porque
reversal más tp añadirlo vosotros vale esto da una media móvil para cerrar y a los que ya viste
esto pa terro profita terro briqui en porcentual bueno está todo acordaros que hay un montonazo
vale hay un montonazo os he etiquetado todas vale porque así ya veis en la pantalla es s 35 s 34
s 33 vale con el número de que es que es vale long exit short exit vale y en y en entre es long
entre l y s vale esto por supuesto os lo doy intentaremos no lo tengo aún hecho pdf lo pasaremos
a un pdf a ver que pasarlo aún a un pdf y subiremos el código y el pdf vale este no no o sea es que
easy language ya es lenguaje hablado yo creo que todo el mundo lo va a tener lo que voy a hacer es
copiarlo porque si lo tengo que hacer el lenguaje hablado me va a llevar a 200 horas que ya me ha
llevado 200 hacerlo pero es que ya se entiende o sea explico es decir el easy language es es
realmente muy cercano al lenguaje hablado es un lenguaje de muy alto nivel y es muy muy cercano
por lo que yo creo que tampoco hace falta cada entrada cada salida si alguien no entiende alguna
que me lo pregunte si alguien no entiende alguna que me lo pregunte que nos lo pregunte en el
discord y se lo aclaramos pero yo creo que copiando y pegando el texto directamente vale para aquel
que no pueda compilarlo en un easy language lo ponemos en un pdf que lo pueda copiar y
trasladar a lo que quiera la idea pues yo creo que ya vale pero esto no era propiamente de hoy
pero si os lo quería presentar y entregar porque creo que es un código nuevamente
material creo que bastante útil bastante bastante útil tengo un workspace y también
os lo os lo pondré ahí también en esto es lógicamente sólo sirve para aquel que tenga
aquel que tenga tres station pero tengo un workspace donde estás curso prácticas clases
cada una de las vale bueno simplemente es para que lo veáis que digo con esto podíamos haber hecho
sólo una que se entera pero pero aquí pues eso que os digo vale al final tú es aquí tienes es
23 long entry vale esto los estos los que le solos no se etiqueta este es la 23 entonces así lo veis
ya en pantalla cual tenéis simplemente tú tienes aquí los inputs de todos pero los primeros son
entrada salida periodo entra periodo salida 15 entrar a 23 con salida 2 perfecto luego además yo
tengo aquí los inputs 0 2 0 5 ya veo rápidamente a qué se refiere cada uno de 14 5 17 20 a todos
le he puesto vale para que rápidamente los que tenían un input la otra vez estaban como
aprovechados ahora no cada entrada y salida tienen el suyo aunque esté usado en otro para
que sea fácil el 31 pues son estas el 30 pues son estas 29 pues son estas vale yo ahí puedo
con un mismo código ir probando distintas combinaciones vale distintas combinaciones
pero esto ya digo está aquí en el sb lo podéis poner en cualquier activo y probar lo que queráis
entraría tal podéis ir probando de manera rápida vale cómo funciona una entrada una salida y a
partir de ahí ver por dónde tirar porque esto os va a dar mucha pista de qué tipo de estrategia va
mejor para cada activo os va a dar una pista bastante bastante potente insisto con el objetivo
de hacer las vuestras un ejemplo para que hagáis las puestas a partir de ahí tengáis un módulo de
útil interesante potente decir que sirve y todas las salidas están todas prácticamente además recordar
muchas ya pre instaladas pero bueno se puesto todas ya en un mismo código pero con el objetivo
de que vosotros hagáis las vuestras vale vamos con el money management que era lo que tenía
tratado nuevo es verdad que casa o casa no era pero pero era creo importante todo todo esto vale
entonces qué vamos a ver sobre como os decía vamos a trabajar sobre todo sobre todo en msa
sobre todo en msa acordaros pero tenéis las las prácticas y la teoría la que ya enseñé alguna
cosa de msa hoy vamos a enseñar alguna alguna más pero una más encima y más detalle vale pero
también vista las preguntas y comentarios que he ido recibiendo pues voy también insistiendo en
aquellas cosas que creo que son más útiles necesarias o que veo que quizá podéis ir más
más verdes vale más verdes esto al final es el material que yo utilicé para hacer las clases
teóricas no voy a hacerlo todo pero simplemente se quería recordar algunos casos algunos casos en
cuanto al tema del martín gala y anti martín gala porque esto es un tema realmente muy importante
que tristemente aquellos que operáis pues seguro que lo habéis visto está relativamente de moda y
hay gente que aún las defiende y al final las martín gala simplemente se inventaron para superar
la vez ventaja del sistema entonces nosotros lo que tenemos que hacer es encontrar ventajas de
acuerdo y no tratar de con la con algo que no tiene ventaja pues conseguir que gane vale esa
es un poco la idea si yo tengo ventaja no tiene ningún sentido la martín gala es más efectiva
es más efectiva y mejor para manejar la vuestra vuestra cuenta vale de todas maneras vamos a ir
ahora de mesa a trabajar como siempre un caso un caso real aquí a ver porque quería llegar yo a
un sitio pero esto lo vamos a ver vale quería llegar aquí llegar aquí llegar a los algoritmos
de posicionamiento solo no te vas a llegar aquí vale porque aquí vamos a ver un poquito de código
porque os hablé de alguna cosita de distintas maneras y demás en la teoría visteis un poco
como lo vimos en msa pero no visteis cómo íbamos desde el código ahora vamos a trabajar desde como
nosotros desde tres station pues enviamos ese ese material a msa por cierto recuerdo aquellos que
no lo vierais o que nosotros es entiendo que debe seguir la oferta esto nosotros no tenemos ningún
tipo de beneficio simplemente le envía un email preguntando si podía haber algún tipo de descuento
y me lo ofreció y os lo puse ahí en el disco vale entonces yo ya os lo dije que os recomiendamos
lo recomiendo tiene pendiente de sacar una nueva versión hace mucho tiempo lo dice y supo que
algún día la sacará pero es un programa que es útil es útil como ahora vais a saber entonces
al final no os compliquéis o no nos al final el moneys management es todo bastante parecido
sí que es verdad que fixe de ratio es un poco distinto a mí me gusta más fixe fractional pero
podéis también probar fixe el ratio de acuerdo y es verdad que en cuentas a lo mejor pequeñas
puede ir mejor porque tiene un crecimiento más lento vale más lento y cuando fixe el riesgo
mantiene de manera constante y proporcional fixe ratios de creciente y es verdad que es un poco
más prudente es un poco más pero bueno en definitiva al final fixe fractional que es esta
fórmula ahora vamos a ir al is language es realmente sencilla y de hecho hasta hasta se
puede hacer a manija para quien es discrecional de acuerdo al final no se trata más que de una f vale
una cuenta y un riesgo y ahí es donde está un poco la madre el cordero como fijamos ese riesgo
como fijamos ese riesgo la manera convencional y más intuitiva y es correcta es el stop es decir
si tu sistema tiene stop de acuerdo a ese denominador le pasas es el stop el tema es que
si aquellos sistemas que tienen stops muy alejados que actúan poco o incluso supongo alguno en una
cartera bien diversificada que no tenga entonces hay que medir de alguna manera ese riesgo entonces
nosotros por ejemplo lo estimamos ahora os voy a enseñar cómo que voy a repetir muchas veces
esto hoy no tenéis que usarlo igual puede no gustaros a nosotros nos gusta pero no es tan solo
el más eficiente creciendo la cuenta para nada es bastante conservador también depende de la f
siempre esto vale pero no tiene por qué ser el mejor vale al final hay muchas versiones que
juegan simplemente con lo que incluyen en ese denominador en ese trade risk porque como veis
es igual que cuando hablamos en drawdown de los ratios de retorno riesgo no el retorno
en el numerador riesgo es muy importante porque actúa de divisor de aquí igual si el riesgo es
1000 o es 2000 pues es invertir la mitad de contratos recuerdo entonces al final es muy
muy importante vale es muy importante y ahora lo vamos a ver ahora me paso ya al alex nosotros
de hecho hacemos algo parecido a esto no es exactamente igual pero hacemos algo parecido
al volatilidad de avanzar de acuerdo algo muy parecido de hecho es y no es para nada el más
eficiente pero sí que suelen momentos de fuerte volatilidad pues suele reducir rápido y eso es
importante pero veréis veréis que tiene un tiene algunos problemas y nosotros los hemos solucionado
de la siguiente manera que vais a ver esto ya lo vimos en la práctica bien vamos primero al
al código vía easy language para llevar los datos a msa yo al final msa vale que insisto que os lo
os lo recomiendo al final no es más que un programa en el que yo le tengo que llevar trades como le
llevo los trades bueno esto la ayuda lo explica pero básicamente hay o bien leyendo un performance
report o bien que por ejemplo ya importa cuando tú le pones un sistema un sistema nuevo y tú le
añades un sistema puedes bien cargarle ya un archivo de eso ya es para abrir uno que tienes
vale no por folio no folio no no sea fail vale cuando yo meto un sistema y le quiero añadir
datos al final tiene como unas plantillas espera que esto ya es cuando ya se ha cargado data son
los otros tiene como unas plantillas vale que detectan que te van a decir igual y ahora te
pongo cualquiera luego no lo importaré no lo importaré sólo es un archivo de excel pero
eso es lo que lo que veáis esto vale porque aquí tiene distintos plantillas de formato vale
ciertas plantillas de formato ves tiene tres station tiene bright ray ya veréis que es en
general esto le ayuda os lo os lo explica vale pero normalmente si tú tienes tres station lo
puedes llevar bien leyendo un performance report que lo lee o bien usando esta función que ahora
os voy a enseñar que es bastante práctico es un poco cuando saque alguna versión pues acara más
más posibilidades como lo como lo como lo saca esto vale de momento os voy a enseñar la función
el programa trae esta función que es una función bastante compleja que viene muy bien explicada muy
bien comentada y aquel que quiera avanzar un poco en código pues es interesante porque puede
poder también aprender con ella tiene bastante explicado pero al final no es más que una función
que genera exporta información a un archivo texto o csm mediante pues simplemente importa
pues por supuesto fechas horas y lo la información que necesita para recoger los straight aquí ahora
se abrió el precio de compra precio de venta el resultado etcétera vale y para que veáis todo
eso es perfectamente imposible con palabras reservadas de easy language al final mediante
un código que no vale la pena ahora profundizar en él este código lo da msa está explicado la
ayuda pues te genera un archivo que lo hace con esta función palabra reservada que se
llama fila pen que genera un archivo ya está genera un archivo escribe perdón envía escribe
información en un archivo y qué información escribe pues toda esta vale toda esta que está
aquí que la imprimen este en este archivo y por lo tanto tú a través como cualquier otra función
de acuerdo tú sabes que tienes 1 2 3 4 5 6 inputs puedes usarla en el código vale para extraer
información el primer input es el riesgo segundo el stop de largos stop de cortos el periodo de
aterre la conversión de divisa y la ruta esto ahora mismo no es importante simplemente que
entendáis que mediante el uso de esta función de msa aquellos que lo vayáis a usar pues podéis
podéis exportar fácilmente los datos más fácilmente los datos vale esto siempre se
mete en un en un if last ballon chart vale para no hacer procesar todo vale para que no se procesen
todas las barras o se procesen la última barra del gráfico y primero esto simplemente es para
sacar información al msa se ejecuta y punto como siempre digo no obligamos ni recomendamos
específico no sé que os lo recomiendo es igual que aquel que no hubiera que hubiera conocimientos
de ningún lenguaje le recomendamos el lenguaje para empezar ese haya lo comenté al principio
si os lo recomiendo vale ahora es obligatorio bueno no es obligatorio hay otros programas y
directamente dentro de tres session tienes multichart al maestro que lo veremos el próximo
día y también se puede mirar esa monetaria también allí pero msa la verdad que es un programa
sencillo de manejar fácil muy enfocado en eso vale y es muy útil y la verdad no recuerdo el precio
como salía pero con el descuento este donde está el disco que no lo veo aquí el disco aquí pues esto
no sé dónde lo puse el material el descuento de msa ponen bienvenido igual no un buscador
gracias pues no sé pero lo busca en todos los charches todo que material no me ha salido
no me ha salido a coño aquí sí sí vale 100 dólares de descuento con este con este
no sé cuánto salía a ver lo miro 400 bueno si lo pagas en unos 400 euros pues sale por 300
euros por 300 euros pero no es caro no es caro y viene bastante bien pues estoy a cada uno repito
yo para analizar la gestión monetaria os lo recomiendo entonces de esta manera nosotros
sacamos a msa nuestras estrategias cuando queremos analizar el ms a que se puede hacer
en otros sitios pero cuando queremos hacer en msa lo hacemos ahí bien como sacamos nosotros el riesgo
esa es una de las maneras cuando tú no tienes un sistema con un esto pijo y que actúa frecuentemente
vale esa es una de las algoritmos que más usamos ahora vale hemos usado distintas versiones de
acuerdo pero esta es la que usamos ahora simplemente tenemos una que ya habéis visto el average
normalizada de true range esto es la volatilidad pero medida en porcentaje calculada así vale al
final se calcula de cada día el rey el true range que es el mayor de estos tres esto es el true
rey se divide por el típico al país se multiplica por 100 por una representación gráfica sin más
multiplicarlo por cien es porque en pantalla pues se ve a 1.6 no se ve a 0 16 porque si va a ser
intradía pues a lo mejor se ve 0 21 por ciento y si no pues sería 0 0 21 es como menos vistoso
entonces por una tema de representación gráfica se multiplica por cien entonces esto no deja de
ser el rango porcentual el rango porcentual medio en que se mueven de cada activo de acuerdo entonces
usamos eso como estimador de volatilidad porque esto ya lo comentaba desde la práctica el atr
tiene el letero no problema que ya lo habéis visto muchas veces en activos de muy largo plazo aquí
tenéis abajo cargado espera que no sean cargados en el mismo periodo vamos a cargarlo a 22 porque
es un mes estamos en diario y hasta vale pues al final a la que cargas bastante tiempo se nota
mucho de acuerdo el de abajo es un buen estimador de volatilidad el de arriba no lo es de acuerdo
ahora está muy alta y no es verdad que esté alto está alto porque ha subido el precio es
claro es comparable de entendés entonces es como estimador de volatilidad no es un buen estimador
de volatilidad en mucho plazo en cambio el de abajo si lo es es un buen actual que está en un
rango ahí bastante estandarizado normal en cambio de arriba pues pues no lo está porque final que
no mide puntos los puntos de ahora no son los mismos de acuerdo es el de abajo es el que usamos
vale pero luego lo convertimos a puntos actuales porque lógicamente hay que convertirlo ahí la gran
la gran cosa o la cosa que os recomendamos mucho es este cálculo que hacemos con el max list tenemos
un input simplemente un input que puede ser la volatilidad media un poquito más esto ya depende
la sensibilidad que le quedamos dar como como muy poco la media histórica del activo que esto
también lo habéis visto que lo en algún gráfico lo hemos metido y es muy fácil los enseñado como
se decía acumulando habéis visto ya para que nunca sea menor que es esto esto hacemos repito
estoy midiendo la volatilidad del activo la volatilidad del activo yo la uso mediante este
normalizado pero lo paso por un max list entre estos dos valores el valor de la volatilidad que
habéis visto el gráfico más uno que es un input porque porque no quiero que sea más baja que esa
nunca es decir si yo este valor le pongo vamos a suponer 1 vale que es 1% y la volatilidad es 0 5
de acuerdo la volatilidad es 0 5 el valor que va a tomar esta variable es 1 se entiende no es
decir imaginarnos esta línea que la he pintado ahora y tiene ahora vemos por es 1 60 1 si es
demasiado baja quizá no bueno es igual está bien vale es 1 vale entonces quiere decir que
de esos momentos donde está por debajo de ese 1 que hay algunos no muchos el valor que va a
tomar no va a ser este este tan bajo va a ser va a ser 1 esto porque es esto es porque al final
nosotros lo pasamos como riesgo ahora veréis lo pasamos como riesgo como denominador muy parecido
a lo que hacía avanzar ahora lo veremos pero no le limito no le dejo que tome valores demasiado
bajos porque porque si yo esto lo estoy pasando como el riesgo y no le hago ese límite en momentos
de muy baja volatilidad me va a meter muchísimos contratos vale y sabemos por lo que os decía
antes justamente de cuando va bien un mil reversion como viene un tendencial que los
momentos de baja volatilidad frecuentemente frecuentemente anticipan momentos de fuerte
volatilidad de acuerdo esto es bastante frecuente como veis esto incluso niveles más altos esto
es bastante frecuente como veis vale y por lo tanto esto puede hacer que yo arranque esos
momentos de alta volatilidad de alta volatilidad o de inicio de alta volatilidad y por tanto de
mucho riesgo muy cargado de contratos vale demasiado cargado y ese primer trade o segundo
tercero que si lo acierto bien pero si los fallo me pueden destrozar la cuenta me entendéis y esto
puede pasar entonces una de las maneras de evitarlo es limitar el valor hay varias maneras yo como
siempre voy a tratar de explicar varias para una manera es tener un mínimo y máximo que ya sabéis
que lo solemos tener en el código vale lo solemos tener esto ahora creo que no puedo enseñar los
inputs alberto no puedo no puedo enseñar los los inputs pero bueno a no en este código no lo
tenemos puesto eso vale es que este es el de msa vale vale bueno lo habrá que enseñar si como
puedo enseñar uno del money management del curso no el de apolo creo que lo tenía preparado a ver
lo miro lo miro es mirando tú otros mil apolo pues si ese lo tiene tiene la otra versión con
el modulador pero bueno es igual lo cambian un momento de eso y listo lo pasa que bueno tengo
todo esto aquí que tengo que eliminar claro tengo que eliminar porque si no teníamos que matar aquí
ahora mismo a todo el mundo no sería plan imagínate casa por casa toda españa un lío un lío un
lío grande esto lo voy a hacer así es al final no me lleva a ningún sitio ya hemos visto vale así
que esto lo voy a dejar así partido por cien y por tp esto viene a ser algo algo así estaría
esto preparado para enseñarlo creo que sí bueno no importa mucho pero es igual así lo ven un poco
suele la tierra es suelto de techo de la tb para que la verdad que no recuerdo
no es el target para esto es para esto por esto y viendo lo que es simplificarlo
lo dejo así por si tuviera tuviera doble doble sentido el sistema vale como es el
como es el caso para volvemos a donde estábamos volvemos a donde estábamos estábamos aquí vale
estamos aquí tenemos una variable ajuste que simplemente recoge la volatilidad pero
insisto en el límite de acuerdo que quede claro esto que esto es arbitrario de hecho
ahí en ese sistema acabo de ver y era un inmedio que lo que era que era real para que lo veáis
vale no se supone que sea este límite vale y metese a ese por debajo de uno y medio toma
uno y medio para arriba si toma más porque es el denominador y puede restar puede bajar
mucho los contratos pero lo que no le dejo es subir demasiado por decir tengo esa limitación
no te sé que eso estoy frenando crecimiento exponencial eso es una es una variable conservadora
de acuerdo una variable conservadora una variable que va a hacer que gane menos seguro que seguro
que va a hacer que mi cuenta crezca más lentamente seguro vale a cambio de pagar ese precio pues soy
mucho más conservador en abruptas caídas y porque por ejemplo no este ejemplo que os
ponía aquí esto todo esto es real y todo esto se ha operado esto debe ser el covid no debe ser el
covid o no pues 2008 no eso es el covid yo vengo ahí en el covid bueno soy poco poco no soy muy
muy jaimito muy jaimito porque eso lo puedo hacer aquí venga y tal por cada uno es evidente en qué
periodo es pero así ahora cuando me mueva lo encuentro más fácil es porque si no es el problema
que tiene aquí estamos vale mira justamente ahí podéis tener un ejemplo aquí no hay arriba de
bores malas porque éste es el que exporta msa vale y lo hay exporto sin gestión monetaria
exporto bruto porque allí le aplicaré vale y le aplica pero para que entendáis la idea no caros
aquí que yo vengo con poca volatilidad todo lo que está debajo entonces yo aquí estoy metiendo
muchos contratos me está yendo muy bien lo que os digo veis estoy petándolo se petando no porque
voy haciendo largos y largos que bien fallo uno pero pierdo poco aquí ha cuidado que ya meto uno
y ya fallo más me dan me dan un poquito ahí acabo el stop vale aunque ya empezaba a subir la
volatilidad por lo tanto ya ha empezado a reducir un poco de contratos seguramente siguen siendo
muchos tenéis entonces el problema es real aquí no se ha acabado de ver que no acaba de ser porque
afortunadamente este movimiento fue más o menos paulatino vale fue más o menos paulatino el tema
es si a veces ese brusquedad se produce de manera más abrupta que esta vale a ver si
hay alguna que lo sea es arlo ido a mirar del tirón la verdad que no recordaba como había como
había ido y por ejemplo aquí tiene que ser que venga de abajo realmente pues hayan pérdidas
fuertes no el 2008 2008 ya estaba volátiles realmente el 2008 no es un buen ejemplo para
casi nada porque era el 2008 era bastante fácil de predecir en el sentido de que venía ya al
mercado claramente 2008 de lehmann vino avisado no lo siguiente de hecho estábamos con la volatilidad
altísima ya el mercado ya había caído y vino le mal y acabó de reventarlo pero ya estaba altísima
bueno altísima pero ya estaba alta y estaba bueno creo que se entiende a encontrar un ejemplo
ideal pero creo que se entiende esto ya digo tanto por experiencia como lo hemos vivido pasa
aquí aquí tienes un ejemplo aquí tienes un ejemplo el mercado empieza a girarse y tú tienes
tienes aquí largos tienes aquí largos y estás casi en mínimos de volatilidad estás abriendo a
volatilidad de 1 3 1 29 lo cual estás metiendo muchos muchos contratos y fallas vale claro que si
luego la volatilidad sigue subiendo tú vas a ir ajustándote pero no siempre verás que te la vas
a ir tragando con demasiada bola con muy poca volatilidad vas a tener fallos gordos incluso
consecutivos te van a provocar una pérdida demasiado grande entonces una manera de controlar eso es
limitar limitar el número mínimo de contratos esto se puede hacer de varias maneras también
aquí en un código real vais a ver cómo lo como lo lo pasamos siempre esto creo que alguno ya lo
habíais visto pero para que lo veáis vale cómo pasamos siempre el money management vale ese es el
filtro que os decía vale y luego hay el m m bar y un min size y un max size si tú quieres aquí
puedes limitar el mínimo decirle bueno yo puedo hacer que puedes cero puedo hacer que el cálculo
de cero que los mínimos solo pere 2 o pere 3 o lo que quiera y el max es lo mismo y yo puedo hacer
que no pase nunca de 10 de 20 etcétera puedo jugar con esas dos variables a maneja limitando
el crecimiento y luego hay esta manera que ya habéis visto acuerdos limitando este este con esta
buena variable que ahora no está esa no era el filtro terreno ahora no era esta esta no me acuerdo
algo así es el periodo del de la tere que usamos para calcular que está normalmente es estable en
diario usamos 15 nuevamente y este fila de que puede ser pues uno y medio por ahí vale algo lo que sea
esto ya es un poco depende y automáticamente de esta manera limitamos lo que os decía que la
volatilidad no tome un valor demasiado bajo esto está mal así así y aquí simplemente esto es la
volatilidad de acuerdo esto es esta volatilidad con este max list le quito el porcentaje de acuerdo
le quito el porcentaje falta otra cosa que me ha dejado falta esto vale lo multiplico por el
typical price y luego lo multiplico por el big point value me vuelvo aquí porque aquí lo tengo
comentado y ahora os lo explico mejor os lo explico mejor aquí os lo explico mejor es tengo el valor
de la volatilidad lo divido por 100 que simplemente esto es quitarle el efecto escala para el gráfico
que habíamos puesto simplemente lo dejo en su valor numérico sin porcentaje de acuerdo esto
recordarlo hecho así pero en programación es mejor práctica hacer esto vale que lo sepáis es
mejor multiplicar que dividir siempre que podáis siempre que podáis en un número redondo si no es
redondo ya igual ya lo compensa pero lo siempre que podáis es mejor que sea multiplicar que dividir
vale entonces hacemos esto lo multiplicamos por el typical price es decir lo hemos vuelto a
puntos esto simplemente es deshacer el efecto que hemos hecho con la volatilidad porcentaje pero
tener en cuenta que yo le he calculado en porcentaje ahora la paso a puntos pero la paso al final a
puntos día a día la calculo en porcentaje de los 15 días y el valor que de 1.6 1.3 1.4 evidentemente
lo paso a porcentaje porque lo multiplico por típica el price se mete por close pues mira hay
un punto de manía y hay un punto de que el típica el price al final no deja de ser una media por
tanto está un poco más centrado que el close que es un único dato al final típica para eso
en tres datos hay más low más close partido por tres es un dato un poquito más centrado y por lo
tanto por eso lo usamos pero si usas el close es perfecto no hay ningún problema vale esto es
efecto volatilidad vale y luego lo multiplicamos por big point value para añadir el componente
nominal o precio de acuerdo y esta es la variación vale esta es bueno la variación la variación
respecto al volatilidad y al volatilidad y clásico de avanzar es que él simplemente pone la tr en
el denominador nosotros usamos una tr normalizado en porcentaje limitado a que no pueda tomar valores
más bajos de un determinado valor y además lo multiplicamos por el valor del punto por el valor
del punto esto si veis aquí vuelvo ahora al otro aquí está comentado este otro risk porque
eso es el nominal antiguamente por ejemplo o en una ck por ejemplo si tú operas un vehículo que
que es que no te permite apalancar que no te permite apalancar esta es la manera de calcular
nominal esto típica el price o close para ser en este caso para ser más ortodoxos mejor el close
porque es el valor que toma el regulador como cierre del mercado de acuerdo entonces al final
sería close por big point value el valor del futuro o del activo en cuestión eso es el valor
nominal que tiene el activo que operas y por lo tanto es lo que vale multiplicado lógicamente por
las acciones que tú tengas abiertas sería el valor de tu posición pero si yo lo paso en el
denominador hago cuenta por f partido por esto por risk calculado así lo que estoy invirtiendo
es el nominal de la cuenta desde si yo tengo 100 mil euros estoy y le pongo 100% en esa f
lógicamente aquí le pongo 100 automáticamente se meten al 100% de la cuenta de acuerdo o dicho
de otra manera la f regula el porcentaje de la exposición que yo tengo si yo me quiero
exponer un 100% usando esto y poniendo como f 100% automáticamente invirtiendo el 100% entonces
en vez de usar el nominal usamos una mezcla ante volatilidad normalizada con un límite insisto
multiplicado por el punto vale si fuera sólo nominal todo esto simplemente sobraría esto al
final la diferencia entre el nominal y este y este algoritmo es esto sólo es esto es nominal
repito si le pongo cierre es igual casi es nominal esto es nominal por lo tanto es nominal
por volatilidad podría hacerse dividido es que no importa ahora no vais a entender por qué bueno
más que muchos lo habéis entendido pero voy a tratar de añadir otra capa para explicarme
mejor vale de porque no importa al final todo esto está multiplicado y dividido por tanto no
importa y va en el ratio que todo está multiplicado y dividido por lo tanto al final todos los datos se
van podemos decir auto ajustar cuando yo los los es decir si yo en vez de hacer este cálculo de
ajuste dividido por 100 no divida por 100 pues no importaría y si en vez de multiplicarlo lo
dividiera todo por ajuste pues tampoco importaría entonces al final porque al final es un producto
ya sabéis aquí los factores otro producto vale entonces al final no importa y una división es
un producto hecho acordaros que esto es lo mismo que esto y de hecho como os he dicho es mejor
práctica hacerlo así así ya no hay ni división esto acordaros que es el risk que yo paso al
denominador que es al final fix el risk fix el final es esto es esto yo aquí lo calculo separado
para tenerlo con tresor pero es esto esto es fix el risk el número de contratos largos o que
abriría yo es la cuenta más el beneficio que es el de profit más el open position profit es decir
la cuenta inicial más el beneficio por una f que se me va a que la multiplico por 001 porque me
gusta más ponerle en porcentaje por lo que os decía antes simplemente de un aspecto visual es decir
aquí a mí me gusta más poner 100 por 100 lo que decía nominal no yo podría decir por 100 por 100
podría 100 por 100 porque al final eso es el tiempo de la cuenta porque luego lo multiplico
por 001 de esa manera le quito el porcentaje vale y lo divido por el riesgo en valor absoluto vale
el riesgo es esta variable pero podría ser esta o podría ser el stop o podría ser cualquiera
esto al final es fix el risk en un código yo aquí lo separo para largos y cortos si el sistema no
se quiere usar largos y cortos pues se se pone una única variable el lot test trade lo que quiera
y de esa manera sale sale el risk además de eso también siempre en todos estos códigos tenemos
este módulo de redondeo vale que es podéis hacer un copy paste porque es así es muy sencillo vale
aquellos que no que no conozcáis esta palabra no se parece que es importión simplemente devuelve
la parte entera de una fracción para la gestión monetaria os recomiendo encarecidamente hacerlo
así es decir si el número de contratos que sales 4.9 se coge 4 es que es un caso extremo pero es
así no se coge 5 se redondea abajo siempre porque porque yo estoy diciéndole qué parte del riesgo
quiero arriesgar quiero invertir quiero exponer y no quiero que sea más que ese aunque sea poco
más entonces si yo quiero exponerme un 100% de la cuenta no me puedo exponer un 101 si yo quiero
arriesgar un 2% de la cuenta no puede ser un 2,2 un 2,4 quiere que ser un 2 como máximo y la manera
de hacer como máximo es hacerlo así usar importión vale con lo cual me quedó sólo el valor de la
porción el valor de la entera de la fracción es en menos 172 me quedó menos 1 en 4 y medio me quedó
4 vale con importión tendéis entonces si el valor de trade long diera 7,84 esto haría que fuera 7
vale luego además está esto lo divide por round 2 y lo multiplicamos round 2 porque esto es la manera
de redondear imaginaos que hay operaciones que los rondes redondear de 10 en 10 pues en round 2 le
pongo 10 y esto al final me hace que me divida entiendes me hace si yo tengo aquí 100 para que
lo veáis vale yo tengo 182 acciones aquí vale 182 el cálculo es 187 para hacerlo más lo divido
por 10 vale eso da 18.7 importión que hace 17 vale de acuerdo perdón 18.7 importión que se quedaría
por mejor lo escribo no es que vivir porque si lo estoy hablando yo a 187 acciones vale
en las elecciones y esto lo divido por 10 porque quiero redondear de 10 en 10 vale a esto le
hago soy idiota no puedo hacer aquí así no igual solo lo voy a guardar ahora yo esto lo
divido por 10 lo divido por 10 y me da 18.7 estamos de acuerdo no 18.7 pero que hace importión se
queda se queda solo el 18 y entonces me coge 18 por 10 cuanto da 180 y redondeado en múltiplos
de 10 de 187 me he quedado con 180 haciendo este cálculo de trade long o trade short partido por
round 2 a eso le hago importión y eso lo multiplico con el round 2 se ve no esa es la manera de
redondear de redondear en la gestión monetaria os los recomiendo siempre hacerlo así vale y
luego entra el módulo de min list max list en caso que hayáis hecho acordaros que aquí
podés tener un 1 y aquí tenés tener pues 20 por lo tanto yo paso primero trade long en los
dos casos es igual trae long por el max list vale imaginaos que esto ha dado esto ha dado 180
hemos dicho antes vale 180 max list de 181 que es 180 vale ahora trae long vale 180 min list que es
180 20 entre min list que es 20 y me quedo con 20 al final me he quedado con 20 que es el límite
que había fijado como máximo siempre se hace así se pasa primero por el max list luego se pasa por
el min list de acuerdo porque así redondeo el valor máximo y luego me quedo con el mínimo al final
si yo he puesto que de mínimo quiero 1 y el máximo quiero 20 y el valor que entra es 180 me
quedo con 20 se ve no esta es la manera de usarlo el hecho de que haya trae long tres short es
simplemente si quiero diferenciar en acciones para largo o para corto o contratos lo que sea
acuerdo ese es un poco el único criterio no es obligatorio no es obligatorio vale ya está aquí
salían las órdenes de entrada salida ya salió entonces simplemente que quede claro entonces vuelvo
sobre el risk vale quedaros con esto vale que es al final la fórmula vale y esa fórmula es
perdón es exactamente esta fórmula de acuerdo es exactamente esta fórmula está f es el valor
que habéis visto que se llama mmbar equity es start equity más profits vale que es net profit
con open position profit y trade risk es lo que regula la agresividad pero como veis todo está
multiplicado si yo al final tengo que elegir una f y para eso voy a ms ahora vale verdad que al
final el hecho de que yo multiplique como veis antes por 100 o divida por 100 tres risk lo que
va a hacer es que una f sea más grande más pequeña pero al estar todo multiplicado de acuerdo esto es
f partido por tres risk o equity partido por tres risk no deja de ser un valor un número todo eso al
final es un número una n entendéis entonces por eso os decía que este ajuste en sí lo que importa
son los componentes que yo uso y esto sobre todo que limito en la volatilidad acuerdo pero al estar
todo multiplicado y todo el risk al final la f me va a acabar de regular la agresividad es decir los
dos elementos que regulan la agresividad es la f por supuesto y el risk vale y el risk ahí está la
clave es móvil ahí está lo que hace regular la volatilidad lo que hace regular la agresividad de
la cuenta lo veréis muy bien en multicha en maestro pero ya os enseñé en la teoría algún
gráfico de esto se veía por daros aquello de la exposición pero lo volveremos a ver el próximo
día porque quiero trabajar en ese un poco ahora en lo que nos queda al final esto está subida y
bajada de volatilidad es lo que va a dar pero lo va a dar sólo en la parte alta en la parte alta
es decir aumentando el risk aquí para que meta menos contratos de acuerdo de tal manera que aquí
dime qué puedo abrir alberto puedo abrir algo rápido para enseñar esto porque quería he visto
no me acordaba que aquí no había gesto monetaria que abro no está puesta en ese código cualquiera
que opere no si total no abro impulse y nadie está no supongo que sí he visto supongo que sí
supongo que sí supongo que sí supongo que sí a ver si es no no estoy llegando estoy llegando
estoy llegando estoy llegando estoy llegando llegado a no no he llegado para llegó llegó
llegó llegó tu y chapolo que hemos vuelto al lado corto venga vamos a ver si nos vuelven a poner el
culo como un tomate a ver voy a poner un largo mismo largo mismo para ver un poco el los datos
en si no no importa simplemente que veáis que los contratos cambian que veis que los contratos
cambian yo aquí voy a cargar creo que no va a llevar de más a mierda está abricado no vale
perfecto no salen cada si no nos cargará todos así nos cargará todos con un poco de suerte no
no reventará nada y podremos mostrar lo que lo que quiero mostrar vale entonces mientras vuelvo
aquí un poco porque es efect y y notar lo que os digo al final f óptima que él y todo es lo mismo
lo único que la manera de calcular la f o la manera de calcular el risk en algunos ratios cambia
como aquí fix el ratio este sí que es un poco distinto aunque también se puede adaptar y este
avanzar eso que os digo al final en el denominador el pone volatilidad fijaros que nosotros también
usamos la volatilidad pero no sólo no sólo la volatilidad incorporamos el precio como constante
vale porque no te sé que bitcoin value es una es variable porque es depende del precio pero
es una constante es decir no no siempre vale lo mismo de acuerdo lo que pasa que es función
del precio de acuerdo pero siempre vale en el caso del nasdaq 20 en el caso del oro 100 de acuerdo
siempre vale lo mismo lo que pasa que evidentemente al multiplicarse por al multiplicarse por la
volatilidad eso que al final es una manera también de pasarlo a dinero no se da cuenta no te sé que
esa manera de de pasarlo a dinero no lo que hacemos es que sea variable dependiendo de la
volatilidad por lo tanto tenemos el tanto del componente fijo vía precio vía bitcoin value como
el componente volatilidad vía ese ese volatilidad normalizada repito con un límite inferior que
también puede ser superior hay autores que lo hacen que esta misma horquilla que os he puesto
os la os la presentan para os la presentan doblemente de acuerdo es decir tanto por la
parte baja como hacemos nosotros como por la parte alta pero por la parte alta se puede hacer con la
manera que os decía no planteando planteando el planteando el mini el max de acuerdo se puede
hacer y también se puede hacer vía volatilidad es decir igual que yo he hecho aquí un max list
o hacemos aquí un redondío max list o yo podía hacer un mid list detrás de acuerdo entienden
más que eso toma 1.6 y ahora aquí pasa un mid list y lo mismo le puedo poner un fílta tera y fílta
tera como quiera revés vale y automáticamente le paso un valor que no puede ser menor a un valor
y no mayor a otro entonces aquí ahora voy a meter para que lo veáis también el average
normalizado además me la voy a aprovechar para meter el de la media de método estos diarios
22 días así tenemos más o menos un mes vale así esta es la media histórica de todo lo que hay
cargado que como veis lógicamente es móvil pero al final llega a un punto que casi no se mueve es
68 50 170 es probar es probar un poco entonces aquí como veis esto va moviendo entonces aquí
en valores por debajo esto ahora no sé qué valor filtra a ver espérate que ahora se abro esto
pantalla porque esto sí que es el de operar y claro hemos enseñado muchísimas cosas muchísimas
pero claro cien por cien ya igual alberto me mata pues no me mate entonces esto está limitado
en unos 75 por lo que veo no alberto unos 75 vale entonces ese está limitado en unos 75 es así como
como está operando entonces que es más o menos la media de hecho por la media actual pero está
por debajo vale voy a ponerle la línea como está en unos 75 que así lo ya es vale en que
en qué valores es y mira voy a hacerlo la línea que se vea más y mejor blanquita gordita y tal
ahí ahora se va a ver mejor o lo que bien se ve ahora se mejora ahora no se ve mejor se va a
ver mejor en ese unos 75 que quiere decir esto que esto viene desde muy atrás no sé cuando se
había cargado sólo 10 sólo 10 para ver un poco aquí empieza con los cálculos se empieza con 70
porque depende del precio también no olvidéis por eso aquí mete muchos y aquí mete menos ya
lo veréis mucho de msa que en apolo a pesar de ir creciendo la cuenta el crecimiento de contratos
no es tal porque el nominal sube tanto y nosotros metemos el valor del precio en él en el componente
porque creemos que la exposición también es un componente importante no queremos exponernos a más
de n y esa es una manera también de controlarlo a incorporar el precio ahí con el límite de la
volatilidad y estoy evitando exponerme demasiado vale lo veréis muy bien cuando veamos maestro
lógicamente los contratos han ido subiendo pero no de manera lineal donde si se ve aquí quiero
que veáis aquí por ejemplo previo previo una caída aquí mira aquí aquí es que yo aquí estoy
metiendo 26 veis 28 y aquí fijaros como baja la volatilidad y tengo ahí 30 y tengo 29 no sé si
llega a ver lo voy a dejar porque está por debajo de la línea todo el rato aquí realmente no sube
cuando debería de subir porque baja la volatilidad y veis que aún ahí hasta me mete menos porque ha
subido el precio pero estamos aquí 28 29 30 38 que está ganando está subiendo la cuenta y está
bajando la volatilidad esto siguió le quito el límite de hecho lo puedo hacer otra vez lo puedo
hacer le voy a poner ahora cero vale eso pero al momento vamos a ver para que veáis una cosa
que gana mucho más para que veáis que gana mucho más esto es así vale en los últimos 10 años
lado largo ha subido un poco la saco vale pero ahora fijaros que yo tengo aquí 2 19 con 13
millones yo le voy a quitar el límite fijaros aquí que estamos claro también también va a venir más
que nada fijaros la variación porque va a cambiar todo porque va a cambiar desde el inicio vale pero
fijaros aquí por ejemplo que ahí a la izquierda vez que tiene 17 17 26 30 vale va de 17 a 30 17 a
30 17 a 30 y esta zona fijaros se mantiene muy estable cuando llega y no yo le voy a quitar el
límite le voy a quitar el límite le voy a poner cero con lo cual no va a actuar el límite es este
límite entiendo que eso va a limitar ahora y va a cambiar fijaros que ha pasado a 20 millones en
vez de 13 20 pero fijaros lo que os digo aquí hasta tiene tenía 17 aquí tiene 20 pero fijaros
aquí como oscila lo veis 46 49 43 32 30 65 67 lo veis de 30 aquí me ha metido 65 67 claro
va perfecto porque está acertando veis ahí muy bajo aquí ya no baja no sube tanto porque
también sube el precio aquí mete 70 pero como falla y seguramente el cálculo de volatilidad le
ha subido un poco a bueno la volatilidad seguramente no tiene el de abajo espérate que ya que lo hacemos
lo hacemos bien porque esta versión no sé si es la actual para 04 la tierra alberto sí claro este
tenía esta hora ya no pero así pero bueno es igual es muy parecido simplemente esto es para
que para que vean los cálculos vale operaba con 9 entonces por eso veíais más oscilación la media
sí que es la blanca pero fijaros ahí 70 es porque ha subido ha subido la volatilidad
por totalmente menos pero veis cómo reacciona con una tierra más rápido reacciona mucho más rápido
pero veis la enorme variación el problema es ese ahí lo tienes es este me lo mete con 75 aquí ya
se ha ajustado y ha bajado cuando hay una caída fuerte bajará muy rápido bajará muy rápido
eso no es problema el problema es que con baja volatilidad me pille dos o tres fallos importantes
que esto pasa vale y si pasa pues te puede hacer mucho mucho daño vale este es un poco el problema
que puede tener simplemente que lo que lo veis así ahora está aquí está reaccionando sin filtro al
final el sistema va a ganar igual pasa que seguramente a nivel de riesgo tiene momentos
un poco más poco más abruptos vale pero va a ganar igual aquí pensar que hemos cogido una
época donde prácticamente sólo el solo está el covid de grandes grandes caídas fue muy rápido
no fijaros cómo reacciona que llega hasta meter 14 tremendo llega al final a meter en este tan
volátil no es tan volátil al final creo que no le cazo a ninguno muy fuerte no es que es otro
ya ya ya no estoy equivocando a ver este era el antes era de antes este es este es entonces
aquí sí que aquí 144 ya digo genial que vamos a hacer tanto que tenemos unos contratos aquí
no pasará aquí afortunadamente es lo que os decía antes el primer fallo ya le pilla con
un poquito de ajuste de volatilidad ya está ahí ya ves ya se ha levantado un poco ha bajado un
poco más y son 53 contratos y fíjate ya el siguiente le ve de 33 y es de 14 y ve los mal
porque falla lo veis y este es este es el mecanismo que hace este tipo de rato y cualquiera
que ajuste por volatilidad que no es el más eficiente os lo digo porque frena mucho el
crecimiento que veis automáticamente a frenar y bajado el otro si yo lo vuelvo a poner a unos
75 vas a ver que hace lo mismo pero no habrá este rango de 83 a 14 lo que hago es reducir
un poquito 1 1 cuando era unos 75 lo abierto era creo que ese es bastante agresivo de donde se
pone se pone los 75 ves ahí ya tiene 39 42 y 12 es 70 80 no sé cuánto era la mitad arriba está
muy frenado arriba para que para que esa variación no sea tan importante porque si te coge bien bien
se te coge mal te puede hacer mucho daño así lógicamente aquí te mete 42 contratos decir la
cuenta ha crecido y ha ganado mucho dinero tienes pero viste a mí reduce reduce 42 simplemente que
la horquilla es un poquito menor es un poquito menor mediante ese control de no dejar que la
volatilidad tome valores demasiado bajos simplemente para protegerte de los riesgos es una manera
conservadora tú quieres no usarlo puedes no usarlo vas a piñón todo el rato pero con cuidado
porque cuando te pille depende qué sistema depende cada vez que a lo mejor en este caso
usar una tierra como este rápido que reaccione rápido porque esta es verdad que es 9 ahora
usamos 15 es más lento nos gusta más pero es un poquito más lento reaccionar a estos cambios
un poquito más lento pero en determinadas
terminadas cuentas está es un poco la idea ves ahora todo el rato fijaros que está la volatilidad
limitada ahora mismo está a punto de empezar o sea está operando con la misma con este 185 es
bastante agresivo esto es ahora tenemos no acabamos el curso tenemos un simposio interno
de trabajo muy heavy semanas de desarrollo y mejoras de cosas porque aunque la realidad es
que no debería ser así pero la realidad es que tenemos cosas atrasadas no nos da como como ya
os comenté y aquellos que seguid esto le sabéis que no habíamos hecho el curso nunca para porque
por tiempo aunque gracias a toda la ayuda de victor que ha sido muy importante en la parte teórica
no puede haberla lógicamente y realmente el freno a nuestro día a día está siendo tremendo es así
por eso al final ahora pues habrá que trabajar duro para muy fuerte para aún así insisto el
mes no es por eso es porque el mercado creo que hay trabajo pendiente entonces bueno esto es un
poco lo que hace el algoritmo de acuerdo el algoritmo hace eso funciona de esta manera insisto
yo os recomiendo trabajar con fixer risk es muy cómodo y ahí ya valorar vosotros cómo trabajáis
el risk trabajar hacer pruebas investigar depende también del tipo de sistema como siempre pero yo
iría a fixer risk y trabajaría el risk probar volatilidad probar nominal probar distintas
combinaciones es un poco el stop al final es investigar pero en ambos todos los casos pensar
un poco lo que os digo del min max de acuerdo puedes bien trabajarlo con algún con algún
cálculo del indicador que uses como este y también como no con el min y el max size de acuerdo
vida de código limitar que no crezca de más x cantidad vale bien volvemos a lo que os decía
para pasar el código y esto simplemente es un código que sólo hace eso sólo pasa aquí
no hay gesto monetario al uso aquí sólo calcula el riesgo pero no en las entradas porque esto al
final genera estos archivos que os he que os he enseñado para estos archivos que os he enseñado
los envía a msa y ya está lo sabes y ahora vamos a dedicarle un ratito vale aquí yo
tengo un porfolio completo de todos los lotes bastante no exacto pero bastante bastante
aproximado a lo que está operando actualmente nuestra cartera alfa es un porfolio que sólo
tiene dos familias de sistemas lado largo y lado corto separado una de las cosas que tenemos ahora
como ya os he comentado pendientes volver el oro a espejo y algunas pruebas pendientes de apolo
además de a ver si de una vez podemos sacar artemisa por volumen por liquidez y historias
varias que varias de ellas son ageras a nosotros pero en algo tengo que meter artemis que hace
años que artemis en un sistema que va muy muy muy bien en este mix entonces bien eso es el
yorikeo nuestro y sigo entonces aquí al final hay un porfolio que es una suma de estrategias yo
estas las puedo abrir vale las voy a abrir ahora para que las veáis algunas de ellas vale para
esas son todas las que son del lado largo acuerdo apolo del lado largo voy a cerrar
este momento no guardo por folio sólo apolo no guardo estos son las estrategias individuales
de apolo esto es lo que os digo esto carga yo abro aquí los datos y esto lo ha cargado ese
archivo acuerdo lo ha generado como lo genera cuando lo cargo ya está automatizado una vez
ya está hecho la primera vez pues ya su trabajo es cargue ese archivo tiene un formato lo que os
decía bright function y esto ya automáticamente le mete la fecha la impresión entrada el riesgo
vale y yo le paso el riesgo mío es como dinero que es al final el cálculo proveniente de esto
de acuerdo esto es el riesgo se calculó yo lo paso aquí como el riesg que me sea lo veis y
ese es el valor el valor de riesgo es el denominador de fixer risk si quiero usar fixer risk porque
ahora vais a ver que yo aquí puedo usar lo que quiera este programa es para analizar
investigar la gestión monetaria yo os he hablado de lo que nosotros hacemos pero ahora aquí vais
a ver las posibilidades del programa y os explico cómo hemos hecho hasta ahora lo que hacemos y
también otras cosas que no hacemos para si las queréis hacer entonces este viene los datos de
ese fichero viene también en la tierra por si queremos usar la tierra etcétera y yo aquí tengo
los datos en bruto tengo los datos tengo la equity table aquí ahora tengo ya aplicado una gestión
monetaria pero el programa me permite no vamos a lógicamente repasar en profundidad el programa
enseñó lo imprescindible para que lo veáis pero veis aquí tengo lógicamente hay unas opciones de
configuración del setup de qué tipo de futuro el valor por punto lo que hemos adaptado el cfd viene
del futuro pero está adaptado al cfd bueno hay historias no pero al final al final el
posicion size que es lo que más nos interesa yo aquí si le pongo no automáticamente está como viene
es decir un contrato viene si gestión monetaria podría venir también como se monetaria nosotros
lo llevamos sin que sea monetaria automáticamente yo esto está ahí porque yo le he dicho que la
cuenta es de 100 mil y punto y aparte de ello puedo probar cualquier rato y cualquier rato y
aquí en la ayuda los tenéis todos explicados vale sólo por eso ya el programa es realmente útil
porque tenéis todos los ratos explicados cómo van cómo se calculan un montón de literatura aquí
en el apéndice está muy bien métricas en fin de verdad que está muy bien el programa incluso
tiene para cálculo el tiempo real le pones cuánto tiene la cuenta cuánto tal cuánto tocaría de
contratos y tiene un código también para llevarlo al código se nos ha enseñado porque no importa
pero tiene tiene también un código que puedes usar si no recuerdo mal en entre estes son
multichars cogiendo el money management que proviene de aquí vale entonces al final viene
todo muy muy explicado vale pero bueno vamos a centrarnos en lo que hemos visto si esto le
pongo que él y él me la calcula y me meten 23 de ratio de f vale esto da un drop down un módico
drop down de un 31 por ciento de un 31 por ciento que para ser que él y no está mal para ser que
él y no está mal pero ya digo yo puedo aquí hacer pruebas luego cuando yo lo pongo en el
porfolio y ahí los trabajo conjuntamente pero esto es a nivel individual incluso puedo optimizar
de acuerdo yo puedo venir ahí un optimizador vale y que sí que os recomiendo usar a nivel de
investigación como os he dicho siempre es decir yo tengo aquí un posición site y le pongo fixed
risk vale y automáticamente vengo aquí a optimizar y analizo vale y le pongo por ejemplo net profit
con un límite de drop down de 20 por ciento máximo y él busca aquí rápidamente combinaciones vale ya
es muy rápido aquí me ha buscado pues está que la óptima fracción es un 4.1 ya está vale me
he hecho que es 4.11 la óptima que me da justo el 25 está pues yo ahora quiero que me la dé con un
15 perfecto pues lo utilizo y con un 15 me dice que la óptima es un 235 el máximo beneficio pero
limitando la 15 de acuerdo esto puede investigar investigar no quiere decir como digo siempre que
lo que salga es lo que voy a usar puede investigar puedo hacer puede hacer algunas cosas pero no
es objeto tampoco mirar eso puedo analizar algunos parámetros cómo se mueven pintar la curva de
profit de haber straight profit factor distintos factores dependiendo distintos factores como por
ejemplo la volatilidad es igual esto sería un poco temas del programa y no los objetos simplemente
os enseño lo que lo que os digo y lo que os permite analizar la gestión monetaria y el efecto de
distintos ratios que tiene por ejemplo a destacar fixet risk fixet ratio por supuesto los dos
típicos generaliza el ratio que es la forma generalizada de fixet ratio que os lo expliqué
en la presentación y profit risk que es la forma generalizada de fixet fractional vale de separando
profits de inicial nosotros lo tenemos así aunque en realidad no lo usamos lo tenemos configurado
así para que puedas invertir un portaje distinto de la cuenta que de los las ganancias luego tiene
leverage esto es apalancamiento 1 a 1 2 a 1 3 a 1 esto es como exposición de acuerdo es lo mismo
también tiene porcentaje de la cuenta directo también tiene un máximo método de máximo
simplemente que no pueda pasar el trabado de que quisiera que más margen como objetivo
tiene tenemos y tiene también donde está el de avanzar no lo veo ahora aquí pero es en volatilidad
pero es en volatilidad que es el atr si vais a la ayuda os explica todo repito están todos explicados
vale aquel que tenga el programa que lo quiera comprar que como digo os lo recomiendo porque
vale y tiene muchas mucha capacidad de analizar bien curvas y demás y también a nivel de
porfolio de los más baratos que hay a este nivel es un dinero que lo bien invertido
pensé en volatilidad que os explica esto es de avanzar para ti para tapar mi poder pero explica
entonces si el atr como se lo hemos pasado podemos probarlo decir esto como yo se lo
he pasado el atr le puedo poner esto a le tengo que optimizar porque no le he puesto y le digo
pues como por este ratio con 15 cuál sería y me dice que por el atr sería el atr que le he pasado
yo cuidado sería 1 0 1 perfecto pues a este de esta curva de estos ratios yo lo analizo lo estudio
y puedo ver aquí distintas cosas vale la gracia es que lo puedo analizar a cada sistema por
supuesto pero que lo puedo analizar a cada porfolio esta es la gracia aquí lo dije en
la teoría y lo voy a repetir algunas veces más espero durante las prácticas está y la siguiente
mucho cuidado con esto vale mucho cuidado con esto esto lo aguanta todo este porfolio está
ahora fortísimo y ni lo veis ahí y lo está para fortísimos era un drawdown y ni lo veis
entonces cuidado cuidado porque realmente el mode management engaña mucho de acuerdo porque
las curvas son muy chulas son muy potentes el crecimiento es muy importante esto es una
simulación lógicamente de contratos de todos los sistemas y tiene un drawdown de 50% está
muy muy bestia yo puedo aquí además de optimizar también puedo probar a mano que casi es lo que
más os recomiendo sí que os recomiendo hacer algún estudio para analizar uno y otro y aprender
y conocerlo y entender pero luego ya casi os recomiendo más usar probar vale aquí por
ejemplo usar todos igual puede tener sentido aquí es bastante parecido porque están ecuadizados
de manera parecida pero pero es igual si no pues se puede poner a cada uno ahora 05 vale a todos
a todos a todos le ponemos el mismo 05 vale y automáticamente 05 me va a decir que tengo
ya un 28 por ciento de darón siendo interesante aquí ya veis el crecimiento de todo el porfolio
lógicamente si quiero ver fechas más cercanas pues puedo hacerlo de hecho
se podía hacer zoom pero a veces esto se cuelga a ver si puedo hacer zoom aquí
a la que te sale se desactiva ahí estamos vale un poquito depende un poquito del ratio de
eje simulataria que usemos entonces lo que os quiero decir es que las curvas al final
esto pasa también en los sistemas a la que ponemos que es monetaria ese crecimiento exponencial
que tienen camuflan un poco las las caídas y siempre las minas las menos valoramos porque
además la realidad que siempre va a ser peor entonces al final hay que ser muy prudente y
por eso en caso de duda tirar como os decía redondear abajo limitar el crecimiento de los
contratos decir cuidado vale porque al final es muy tentador meterle más caña porque lo
vas viendo aquí tú ahora le vas subiendo pues gana mucho más gana tal hostia y total bueno
drawdown 5% más poder luego lo recupera que haya cuando estás en drawdown no piensas recuperar
al final se hace duro entonces eso yo os recomiendo prudencia extrema de acuerdo prudencia extrema y
un nivel de conservador de conservadurismo muy muy elevado pero sí que podéis investigar un poco
a nivel yo os comenté ya que nosotros cuando son familias nos tratamos de manera conjunta yo por
ejemplo tengo un porfolio aquí de apolo solo y de nemesis solo un poco para todos los mix como
trabajan de acuerdo para ver cómo trabaja un nemesis con su largo lado largo y corto y lo
mismo como trabaja apolo con su lado largo y corto solo es apolo trabaja bastante bien por
lo que apolo trabaja bastante bien nemesis trabaja no trabaja mal o talja peor porque
es un tendencial puro y los sentidos puros fijaros veis lo que lo que hablaba y los enseñado
nosotros lo hemos operado y llevaba ahora por ejemplo ha vuelto a despertar y llevaba un tiempo
bastante largo que es lo que os digo parece que no pero es largo y aquí fijaros larguísimo vale
y ya como os he comentado el oro ha deteriorado mucho tendencia no es fruto solo del de sobre
optimización porque incluso este periodo optimizado da estos datos es decir no tendéis ya no no es un
tema de cambio de dinámica de mercado que esto pues ocurre y ha pasado pero esta parte como veis
pues ha estado aquí mucho tiempo en drawdown sufriendo mucho al final ha hecho máximo parece
que está otra vez respirando vale parece que está otra vez es respirando y la cartera de apolo
pues al revés ahora parece que ha estado también ha pasado sus momentos fijaros aquí la cantidad
de tiempo que pasa de acuerdo y esto ya digo es fruto incluso pero siempre yo puedo ser que
está este optimizado fijaros no decir final todos los sistemas tienen la clave un poco es que yo
ahora cargo esto 2003 los tengo cargados más o menos igual espérate que le quito fijaros como
aquí este buen momento viene con este malo y ahora aquí este que venía muy bien este venía más
flojo y ahora parece que este está bien y es está mal se ve no esto no va a ser siempre así y
lógicamente como como ya os he dicho estos sistemas empastan muy bien y tienen un mérito
enorme que con dos familias del sistema consigamos diversificarnos también pero sabemos
que tenemos camino de mejora como ya he dicho mil veces no me escondo de ello y hay varios motivos
por el que no se hace ya no he explicado no quiero incidir pero el principal principal siempre han
sido los futuros pero ahora veis apolo pues ha entrado a ir un poquito de verdad esto está
actualizado hasta el viernes pasado creo vale entonces entrado ahí en un en un drawdown que
pues bueno ha caído con cierta velocidad que parece que no es tanto pero si lo es de acuerdo
si lo es aquí al final está en drawdown del 6% es para que no solo solo apolo apolo metió un 6%
en nada en apenas una semana con este nivel de gestión monetaria no tiene por qué ser la de la
cartera es un ejemplo para que lo entendáis pero que te quiero decir que el máximo aquí es un
14 15 y fíjate que ya están 6 aquí no prácticamente es la mitad 6 7 casi prácticamente
es la mitad decir tenéis y no lo parecía si no así así así prácticamente ha hecho la mitad
de la hora ahora es un dragón histórico casi casi y ahí no lo parece ni que sea no es por eso os
digo que cuidado siempre siempre tiremos a prudente ya tenemos a prudente pues aquí tienen
que mezclarse entre sí y lo ideal es mezclarmos aquí por ejemplo nosotros y ese objetivo ha sido
siempre ese problema que hemos tenido principal a esta cartera pero vosotros tenéis que buscar
vosotros los consejos que os doy el mix nasdaq oro y por ejemplo luego el pun alemán o
un bono americano va muy bien casi mejor os recomendaría el bono europeo vale va muy bien
este mix entonces hay que ver sistemas que tengan poca correlación entre sí por eso decía que con
tres tipo de sistemas que luego los puedes evidentemente buscar distintos set distintas
zonas que entre sí tengan una moderada diversificación esto al final lógicamente entre sí dices hombre
todos son nemesis sí bueno todos son nemesis pero vais a ver que los hay muy muy parecidos como este
pero este ya no se parece tanto verdad y ahora que vamos con el corto pues todavía menos entre los
cortos hay un poco más de parecido pero tampoco lo veis cómo cambian a pesar de ser el mismo sistema
si tienes si trabajas sistemas robustos temas que van bien en muchos tipos de frame etcétera
al final puedes conseguir que un sistema como este que es el lado largo los 2 2 y 3 veis como
cambia realmente la curva y es el mismo seguramente de una correlación a mejor de 0 6 por ahí es
elevada pero es menos que 0 de que 100 entonces una lógicamente lo ideal es tener 10 sistemas
distintos desglosados en 5 sets y en 5 activos que a lo mejor nos da 50 estrategias perfecto
y es algo que nosotros tenemos la capacidad de hacer y que el motivo de no hacerlo es sobre
eso ya es sabido por todos pero que aún así hay que buscarse la vida y tratar de conseguirlo
también tratar de hacerlo mejor de lo que lo que hacemos se ve que tener esta mentalidad pero es
verdad que cuando tienes cierto dinero se complica al menos para nuestras estrategias y esta plantea
problemas porque es muy bien para cuando el bloque de es bueno hay que vigilar porque los
hay muy piratas pero es por ejemplo es un buen broker el cvd pues da muchas posibilidades
te permite diversificarte bien y es una herramienta que puede ser útil pero como comentaba antes en
el disc o no hay debate sobre si que es mejor el futuro de cfd el cfd lo que lo que yo quiero
insistir es que la obsesión porque hay gente que lleva esto a una obsesión de sino no es que el
futuro es mucho mejor el futuro es mucho mejor pero si tú no puedes diversificarte bien en
futuros es mejor que te diversifiques bien en cfd es entiendes decir no porque el cfd el cfd no
no voy a diversificar de bien voy a operar solo un sistema en futuros mejor que operes 5 en cfd es
que uno en futuros entiendes ahora mejor operar 2 en futuros que 3 en cfd es bueno estaría dudoso
y ahí dudoso puede que tres antes de saber que verlo porque estás mejor tres no pero me entiendes
ahora si yo puedo futuros pues en futuros si no puedo pues en cfd al final hay que hacer lo que
uno puede muchas veces no lo que quiere sobre todo cuando ya tienes una dedicación profesional que
al final tienes que operar muchas veces pues igual que cuando por ejemplo operaba en determinados
futuros y no podía operar otros porque el regulador no me permitió operar el oro por ejemplo hubo épocas
en futuros porque porque su retiro entregable y el regulador pues no te deja yo que sé decir
o no te deja exponerte más de un 100 por ciento no te deja operar lo que sea entonces al final
pueden haber condicionantes operativas por dinero por mil factores vale pero si eso no existe y tú
solo vas a operar tu cuenta pues en principio y por futuros siempre va a ser mejor vale siempre va
a ser mejor y el etf no olvidar el etf tf va muy bien también hablamos de futuros también muchas
veces me olvida porque es verdad que el lado corto pues a veces no va tan no es tan fácil pero sí
que muchos permiten el corto en tiempo real vale entonces también se puede mirar el de acuerdo
no lo olvidemos entonces vuelvo al msa aquí es lo que os decía voy cerrando porque si no me
lío todos los sets que tengo me quedo solo con los portfolios entonces aquí es la mezcla de
todos acuerdo y yo como os decía no tengo la obligación de usar de usar tal incluso puedo
optimizar es verdad que el optimizador esa es una parte que tiene pendiente sobre todo la mejora y
os recomendaría antes hacer una pequeña optimización de todo de cada uno de los sistemas yo aquí los
sistemas los tengo guardados a ver creo que los tenía con kelly pero os recomendaría porque
eso sí que es rápido hemos hecho antes una polo rápido vamos a hacer ahora un m6 rápido vale
lo tengo guardado con que le vale por por guardar uno loco vale es que así veo rápidamente que
de la onda porque que es verdad que sé que tiene un indicador de la calidad del sistema aunque
cuidado que él y él en general penaliza mucho o sea en general el money management ya lo comenté
siempre los sistemas tendenciales salen muy penalizados pero vía por folio de venir bien
por eso ahí monte carlo a veces hasta cosas raras porque porque un sistema como este mira
aquí lo debe lo debe decir y ahora voy con que le vale me da igual es una locura pero
simplemente porque hay que ver eso que os digo vale si el performance report con 100.000 dólares
usando que le vale caros que que le ya me da un valor de 7 de exposición pequeño pero cuidado
cuidado porque recordar que al final todo se auto ajusta porque yo le he puesto un riesgo concreto
aunque que él y no pero aunque él y quería al final calcula una f que depende de
pero pero tendencial es verdad que está está está bastante afectado con mirar una cosa que no me
leía ahora perfecto si no no quería mirar aquí la equidad un segundín aquí creo que le he
pasado aquí estamos aquí aquí podéis ver o también estos que es analizar ves todos los
trades que hace cada estrategia si es el porfolio también vale la fecha de todo el riesgo que le
calcula la f que es lineal en este caso vale para este caso que lotes le salen vale vale y el riesgo
que tenía cada cada por unidad cada cada trade pero aquí cuando es que él y ahora ahora cuando
os ponga fix it fractional veréis que esto aquí cambia bastante y no en que él y porque al final
que él y simplemente es él es lo que invierte recuerdo que él y calcula acordaros que dependiendo
del protege de aciertos poco los componentes de la esperanza matemática obtenemos obtenemos que
y al final el número de contratos como veis es relativamente estable que va a ir aumentando
aumentando aumentando aumentando a nivel de locura pero los tendenciales lo que os digo
normalmente tienen niveles de rotura muy elevados y es verdad que Kelly en ese sentido tiene lógica
y ya los penaliza es decir normalmente un tendencial te va a dar una Kelly más baja que
tendencial vale porque estaba aquí buscando la fórmula aquí la tengo aquí la tengo para
aquel que no la recuerde aunque bueno casi que espérate porque casi que va a ser más fácil
bueno no sé si es más fácil pero si veis otra otra fuente no me es siempre la mía aquí si no
recuerdo mal también exactamente esta vez estaba ahí explicada también estaba ahí explicada y te
viene a explicar un poco el tema vale con el average win los de protege de aciertos los elementos
de la de la esperanza matemática te acaba calculando la f que inviertes acuerdo pero claro como tiene
el r en el denominador vale y el pues eso el r normalmente es un dato elevado en los tendenciales
que tienen un porcentaje de aciertos pequeño pero tienen un ratio average win average loss
general elevado al final eso hace o sea es el divisor de acuerdo como el riesgo entonces
automáticamente provoca que tenga ratios de que él y poquito más bajos aún así aún así vais a
ver que acumula que es lo que os quería enseñar antes antes quería explicaros esto interesante
acumula series de fallos realmente
dependencia no que no a ver dónde estaba esto
número 3 número 3 consecutive wins 8 consecutive losses 15 no sé si no lo puedo
ampliar creo no puedo ampliar creo pero lo voy a marcar a los voy a marcar para que espero
podáis verlo lo voy a marcar yo creo que con el fosforito ver bien esto mira que te digo
creo que esto con el fosforito va a ir bien a ver ahí se ve no 15 vale máximo tiene 8 aciertos
seguidos y 15 fallos seguidos vale esto en el gestión monetario es dramático porque 15 fallos
seguidos es donde casi siempre va a hacer el drag down entonces esto es lo que al final es
una losa gigantesca para los tendenciales como digo que el día afortunadamente bueno afortunadamente
sigue teniendo un drag down brutal del 50 por ciento pero con una f pequeñísima de 7 porque
por eso de componente que os digo vale tienen drag downs muy heavies porque cuando viene la
serie de fallos destruye la cuenta como te pille en un nivel muy alto de equity le va a costar
mucho reducir vale porque no va a reducir más que como no tiene el componente riesgo como la
volatilidad que le va a hacer reducir sólo es por la el descenso de la cuenta al final retrocede
la cuenta relativamente la reducción de contratos es relativamente lenta si vemos aquí esto es
septiembre del 20 que lógicamente se va a notar porque el número absoluto es mucho pero para que
veáis el efecto de kelly en un tendencial también en un antitencial porque encima le va a exponer
más pero aquí el 20 no ha dicho alberto aquí estoy cuatro mil cuatro mil cinco mil seis mil
siete mil aquí va a hacer que baja un poco seis mil aquí a ver dónde veo el drag down está aquí
el drag down a ver mira 12 13 15 10 15 7 aquí 19 aquí 19 aquí drag down mira aquí tiene más 20
29 33 aquí drag down y estamos 30 entonces fijados aquí por ejemplo es 5500 aquí venía en seis mil
7000 llegó a marcar 7100 aquí y aquí me llega a meter 5300 y como eso es una locura pero la
cuenta de creciendo mucho pero para que veáis la reducción vale porque porque al final el riesgo
no le afecta aunque hay volatilidad no le afecta él va metiendo su f su f para que la cuenta va
cayendo claro la cuenta va cayendo bastante es la cuenta aquí estaba en cuatro millones no sé qué
ya que están 3 4 es que le cuesta le cuesta un poco ese ajuste si metes un volatilidad pues
ajusta más entonces lo que os digo aquí te permite este estudio vale y ahora aquí pues digo
venga vale perfecto pues he visto que que él y es 7 vale lo voy a poner fix el fractional 5% qué
pasa a 55 drag down es demasiado 3 45 locura todavía 1% 1% ya estoy en 17 drag down vale perfecto
voy a ver voy a ver ahí qué tal no y ahí ya lo puedo ver pues este crecimiento este análisis lo
que os decía de acuerdo puedo ver un poco esta equidad misma en 2020 que aquí ya veréis mayor
oscilación vale mayor oscilación vale volvemos aquí volvemos a ver el drag down aquí ve 7 va
subiendo lo que era más abajo aquí ya no es tan fuerte el drag down claro que ve un 7.8 aquí
que ve un 8 pero fijaros aquí ves que ya tenemos saltos 1800 600 porque porque mete ahí volatilidad
y éste está contando nuestro riesgo veis ahí la reducción de contratos está demasiado abrupta
es demasiado abrupta pues habría que ver aquí que para el riesgo pasamos todo esto al final
depende del resto que le pasemos y tú mismo aquí ves que esto no te gusta pues oye pues yo quiero
limitar tienes lo elevado que es el riesgo etcétera aquí podéis un poco investigar y analizar cómo
cómo funciona y lo que os digo yo puedo ver aquí en una sencilla optimización que os recomiendo
hacer simplemente para investigar por no complicarnos como es un sistema solo 20 con
la f vale y automáticamente fijaros que me sale una f de 1 19 al 20 vale y quedaros un poco con
los datos tampoco vamos ahora tampoco vamos a actualizarlo no actualizamos más tarde más tarde
gracias muy amable muy amable por todo gracias gracias por todo pero simplemente voy a guardar
esto un poquito para compararlo rápido vale pues yo tengo éste vale y ahora tengo pues
por ejemplo fix el ratio vamos a poner fix el ratio el ratio pasando le pongo solo delta
porque solo va a utilizar una de ellas lo mismo 20% y pues ya está vale y me sale esto sale esto
por fix el ratio y así vale esto esto estoy haciendo una simplificación absolutamente casi
insultante pero para que para que para que veáis un poco lo quiero decir lo habría que ver muchas
más cosas pero esto lo haces un sistema de otros deberéis que cambia bastante el perfil hecho este
quería hacer volatilidad volatilidad al uso el que hace avanzar vale este paz descanse por cierto
este ya os digo que lo como cambia el perfil vale como cambia el perfil de un sistema a otro es que
no no no a veces va mejor fix el ratio depende entonces al final también un criterio de lo que
vosotros consideréis aquí por ejemplo hemos conseguido en el primero hemos llegado bueno en
éste person volatilidad vale al mismo más o menos nivel de riesgo limitado nos ha conseguido un
drago a ver dame algún dato bueno me da aquí a net profit aquí joder dios 987 no 987 mil 987 mil
aquí 330 36 mil bastante menos ratio y aquí el fix el riesgo ha conseguido 5 millones vale 5
millones que han tenido más que cuidado que no estoy diciendo que tengas que operar este por
ejemplo el que parece que ha tenido bastante más es hecho bien o no 5 sino si si 5 millones
y 20 por ciento y este 900 es mucho más es al final siempre pasa la tierra este pasa el fix
el ris pero le he empezado en un contrato y a lo mejor era poco vale porque ese es el problema
de fix el ratio que ya os lo expliqué en la teoría que seguramente al exponer con él con
ese tamaño de cuenta que tiene predefinido empezar con un contrato es muy poco entonces
limita y hay algún estudio hecho interesante sobre sobre eso porque si no lo igualas no son
tan distintos yo te pongo aquí fix el ratio y detail size a ver con optimización cuánto
cuánto queda aquí ha quedado con un draw down del del 7 muy pequeño porque le ha costado mucho
entonces ahora aquí le pongo que empiece con tres contratos pongo que empiece con tres vale y le
optimizo ahora vale y ahora pues igual de otro sigue sigue siendo bastante chulo sigue siendo
bastante chulo es igual a ese era era solo un ejercicio podemos decir didáctico pero ya digo
si ahora me dais apolo que es un sistema más bien antitenencial con una perfil realmente distinto
pues seguramente cambia aquí con que el y fijaros que ya me está dando un draw down de no es que
vamos a ponerle que él y ahora que eso es el porfolio venga ser vamos salimos
folio no tengo abierto a ninguno apolo no tengo abierto a ninguno apolo bueno cierro este y abrimos
lo que sea por lo uno mismo apolo uno mismo por lo uno que me da igual y luego un corto va a ver
los dos que veis cómo cambia la cosa claro corto en bolsa pues es complicado ver es el
corto de actuales que me seguís en tuits lo habéis lo habéis visto nos ha ido a te guz y
calpa te guz y calpa de paseo porque el largo no tanto entonces lo que hablaba lo que hablaba
lo que hablaba ahora pero eso se ha actualizado si se ha actualizado no se ha actualizado este
no se ha actualizado hasta hoy es alberto vale lo que iba 12 de abril ponen 12 de abril el
sol tú no me extraña pero puede ser pues es igual no importa cero importancia vale entonces
ahora que estoy con que le vale fijaros que aquí tengo 23 y aquí tengo 16 que tiene peor
propiedades el sistema es obvio que le calcula eso pero yo ahora mismo volvemos un poco a fixed
fractional y aquí le ponemos a mano a mejor el uno nos va a ir más o menos bien y a los 7% está
poco expuesto este al 1 pongo 2 2 entonces puedo ver un poquito pues pues donde donde respirar
de acuerdo hay que verlo con el mix largo corto por eso estaría bien incluso podría mezclarlos
en uno y aquí no lo he hecho pero podía ver en un mismo archivo mezclarlos y es buena práctica
de acuerdo pero también puedo hacerlo así porque ahora un porfolio que es lo que he hecho el porfolio
junto y nos analizo juntos es lo que he hecho ahora ahora os enseño vale pero así veo un
poco el mix largo corto aquí estoy en 20% con un 3 con un 3% pero puedo hacer un poco la misma
película y vais a ver cómo fixer risk fixer risk optimizamos lo mismo con 20 no le había puesto
el profit 20 vale por simplificar no vamos a perder mucho tiempo aquí 20 veis y ahora yo aquí
tengo lo que os decía que veis un poco el cambio de un perfil más bien antitenencial vale donde me
está metiendo 321 donde se me está metiendo 321 no sé si el periodo del mismo la verdad no me
acuerdo creo que este tenía un poco más de periodo es un tema que además va en diario ya
la voy a meter volatilidad la voy a meter volatilidad vamos a ver a volatilidad bruta
cómo consigue bajar aquí fijaros que ya tenemos un resultado notablemente peor a
el ratio que exportamos nosotros a pesar de que también es de volatilidad pero no es volatilidad
es volatilidad primero normalizada vale y luego ajustada por el nominal y con un límite de
volatilidad y esos dos componentes pues como veis al principio parecen mejorar el resultado
al menos en estos dos estrategias vamos aquí con fixer ratio para ir acabando y
no no no no no no no no si si si optimizas y ya estás aquí tenemos 15.000 este al final lo
que le está pasando es lo que os digo que está muy infra expuesto mucho tiempo eso no tiene un
dragón del 2 por ciento esto realmente el problema aquí es que habría que meterle a lo mejor de
entrada 5 con grados a lo mejor hay que meterle aquí
inicial size 5 igual le meto 5 y a ver ahora qué delta me saca todavía está con un dragón
ridículo no sé por qué expone tampoco no es al revés a no es al revés lo que tienes poca cuenta
claro claro no no es al revés al revés lo que tienes poca cuenta es equivocando tiene poca poca
cuenta entonces la delta ahora delta de 100 en el óptimo claro no no puede no puede no puede
sacar esa vez tiene falta dinero aquí habría que optimizar la delta y no consigue subirla vale no
consigue necesitaría ahora ya tenemos una delta de 10.000 pero sigue teniendo un dragón pues
muy bajo muy bajo está usando muy poco ahora pero ahora empieza con 5 no ahora pero porque
pido con 5 porque le he puesto 5 porque si no le pongo eso no me lo deja tocar no ahora
sé que es 10.000 y empieza con uno si me lo tardan mucho en necesitar y le cuesta mucho al
final dicen que dicen que fixar va mejor para cuentas pequeñas pero pero bueno ya digo es
es depender un poco del tipo de sistema nuevamente vemos un poco otra vez que
aquí tenemos 1 2 3 26 26 no 2 millones 600 y se ríe siempre se ponen a ti que tenemos
un millón 400 a un nivel de dragón equivalente entonces en principio en principio mucha prudencia
parece mejor pero yo aquí es lo que os digo no quiere decir que usaría un 3 por ciento
esto es lo que os quiero decir no se trata de eso de ver un poco la sensibilidad de hacer análisis
no se trata de eso hay que siempre mezclar los otros que os decía aquí vía polo pasa que no
sé por folio es muy es muy muy poco eficiente optimizador porque aquí no hay muchos sistemas
son diarios este es yo creo que va a ser más o menos viable pero que tengo un tipo esto que
le digo que tengo a ver déjamelo ver que creo que va a ser medio viable sino mientras nos vamos
despidiendo ventas se optimiza pero creo que va a ser medio viable si aquí lo que va a ser
medio viable lo que pasa que a mí no me gusta esto es una cosa de hecho lo envié como sugerencia que
limitara el hecho de que permitiera haber valios no ocurren vale que permitirá limitar que todos
salgan igual no no lo he parado lo parado porque no me acordaba que esto era loco pero
era msa absorberlo de una manera increíble me acordaba nos lo va nos lo va a tirar no puedo
no puedo hacerlo porque no lo puedo limitar de ninguna manera sé que me lo va no lo puedo hacer
bueno ya lo ya lo miraré por lo miraré por por curiosidad como hemos empezado un poco más
no hacer descanso disculparte pero bueno vamos a ir ya acabando el de además jose do net seguro
que ya se habrá ido supongo a ver su su partido bueno a lo que a lo que iba el próximo día me
voy ahora a arriesgar porque ya si no se abre pues me da igual abrir multichars vale trabajaremos
trabajaremos sobre todo bueno las dudas que hayan sobre esto repasar un poquito si tenéis dudas
tanto esta clase como la que vimos de molémanas menú 1 y 2 hicimos 2 en la teoría vale porque
al final ahí hay cosas interesantes entonces aquí veremos un poquito el trabajo de todos
los sistemas y creo que que meteremos alguno más que nos vamos mirando antes vale pero aquí está
todo lo que hemos trabajado vale y veremos un poquito distintas combinaciones haremos distintas
pruebas vale con lo que hemos hecho me acuerdo a nuestro compañero pantalla venga perfecto vamos
vamos vamos con todo vale no estábais viendo nada perfecto vale ahora sí disculpadme no decía
que aquí veis tenéis un poco los sistemas que hemos trabajado y creo que meteremos alguno más
vale pero bueno ahí está ya está todo lo que hemos trabajado ya se ha configurado con unos
conexiones otros con futuros bueno lo que hicimos lo que hicimos el oro de acuerdo y hay distintas
combinaciones para utilizarlo por los ratios que tenemos de porfolio tenemos algunas historias
en el centro bueno ya lo comentaré vale entonces quiero enseñarlo aquí que no sean los multicharts
los dos porque multicharts hay pero maestro a mí tiene cosas que me gustan mucho pero ya os lo
comentaba es muy poco eficiente como programa muy lento y tal entonces por tener un poco los
dos dependiendo como me vaya uno me vaya otro pues usaremos y vamos viendo un poco las dos las
dos opciones vale para ver un poco distintas combinaciones que como veis es muy sencillo
marcas uno desmarcas el otro y ve ya los dejaré más o menos optimizados y analizados para poder
os lo explicar y trabajaremos bastante sobre esto de acuerdo en ver distintos perfiles ver
que aporta uno como vez que mejor de acuerdo ir viendo distintos ratios para para ayudaros
un poco a la elección y ver cómo mezclar el gestión monetaria y porfolio vale también
seguramente algo de excel para ver esta la mezcla de sistemas de acuerdo así que por hoy lo dejo
aquí quería ya digo sentarme en msa yo os lo recomiendo es esto que no es no es para nada la
obligación porque teniendo maestro en maestros para esto tiene la parte la parte de gestión
bastante buena es esta parte aquel que no lo haya trabajado os lo abro brevemente lo usamos
mucho más para unas cosas porque para las cosas va bien tenemos aquí como veis un montón de
morfolios pero para otras va fatal al final pues hay que hay que mezclarlo es aquí tenemos por
ejemplo sistema de ruptura entonces lo que os digo aquí cuando tenéis un strategy group vale este
ruptura acciones vale aquí tiene un modo de modo imbarazment tú puedes llevar el modo
imbarazment vía easy language o puedes usar este y está muy bien porque ves aquí tienes algunos
ya fix fractional y fixate a mountains que es fixar ratios tienes aquí algunos que te pueden
venir bien para investigarlo y demás luego vía código que también os lo enseñaré alguno que
tenemos vía código para como muchos al final habéis habido cuenta en ese lenguaje que veáis un
poco la opción de controlar maestro vía vía código trataré de que lo veamos todo creo que me
da tiempo el próximo día acuerdo y que ya será la última bueno será la última porque la última
última será el no sé qué día de junio dicho antes el 11 era el martes 11 de junio en donde ya
así que nos despediremos y responderemos a todo lo que haya quedado pendiente si ha quedado algo
que vieron que hay varias preguntas generales de repetir o tratar pues insistiremos en ello ese día
de acuerdo así que nada más os veo el próximo martes y pues nada más despedimos aquí la creo
que quinceaba clase del curso te digo amén y co hasta pronto chicos